I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯尼。我们一起演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。
Hello. Hi. Oh my goodness. I walked in and I was like, oh. Hello. Hi. Oh my goodness. I walked in to the most wonderful celebration. It was a surprise. Angela. So you guys, Jenna is turning 50 this week.
你好。嗨。哦天哪。我走进来的时候心想，哦。你好。嗨。哦天哪。我走进了一个超级棒的庆祝活动。这是一个惊喜。安吉拉。所以你们知道的，珍娜这周就要满50岁了。
Yes. And I knew you didn't think we had anything planned, but I arranged with Cassie, I got here early and I made a sign that says it is your 50th, a la Jim and Dwight. Yes. Right? Uh-huh. It's amazing. I had sad streamers left over from some Christmas craft I did, and Cassie brought balloons.
是的。我知道你以为我们什么都没计划，但我跟凯西安排好了，我早早就来了，还做了一个标语，上面写着“今天是你的50大寿”，效仿吉姆和德怀特的风格。对吧？嗯哼。太棒了。我用的是之前做圣诞手工艺剩下的悲伤彩带，凯西还带了气球。
And some partially inflated balloons. We did that. Cassie and I partially inflated them. And then Jordan hung the sign. We did the best we could, but it's actually a little wonky and just perfect. Here is the thing, do not take this the wrong way, but the greatest thing about doing like the office themed it is your birthday decorations is that they can be real bad. I know. And it works. I know. Like it is all on theme and I love it. You have very colorful balloons, which I think is right.
还有一些没充满气的气球。那是我们弄的。我和凯西把它们充了半满。然后乔丹挂好了标语。我们尽力了，不过其实有点歪歪扭扭，但反而刚刚好。是这样的，别误会我的意思，不过办这种《办公室》主题的“今天是你的生日”装饰最棒的一点就是，它们可以布置得真的很烂。我知道。而且效果拔群。我知道。这完全切合主题，我很喜欢。你的气球五颜六色的，我觉得这很对。
It's a milestone year. It is your 50th. It's the 50th. It is your 50th. So I think you get colorful, sad balloons on your milestones. Gray and brown balloons, just FYI, are harder to find. They are, right? Or gray or whatever colors they use.
这是一个具有里程碑意义的年份。你50岁了。这是50岁。今天是你的50大寿。所以我觉得在这样的整数年份，你理应拥有五颜六色、带点悲伤的气球。顺便说一句，灰色和棕色的气球其实更难找。确实是，对吧？或者是灰色，管它什么颜色呢。
Yeah. Oh my gosh. It was a surprise. When I came in the door this morning, I accidentally like punched my knuckle into the metal door handle and I... And we were waiting for you to arrive. I was about to yell, and then I saw you do that and literally Jenna hit her hand and then goes, oh, it was so painful and I was so grumpy as I was coming in.
对啊。哦天哪。这真是一个惊喜。今天早上我进门的时候，不小心把指关节撞到了金属门上，然后我……我们当时正等着你来呢。我正打算大喊，结果看到你做了那个动作，说真的，珍娜撞到手之后就说，哦，太疼了，我进来的时候脾气可暴躁了。
I'm like, oh my gosh, I'm like, I'm here, I'm limping in. And then you guys were like, surprised. I was like, oh my goodness. I went from like this low moment to this high moment. It was so amazing. This is awesome, lady. Yes, my 50th. It's happening this week.
我心想，哦天哪，我心想，我到这了，一瘸一拐地进来了。然后你们就说，惊喜。我当时就想，哦天哪。我的心情从低谷瞬间飙升到高潮。太棒了。这太酷了，女士们。没错，我50岁了。这周就要发生了。
I mean, by the time people listen to this, it will have happened. And you're wearing a Joshua Tree sweatshirt today. Was that for my birthday? Or a coincidence? people listen to this, it will have happened. And you're wearing a Joshua Tree sweatshirt today. Was that for my birthday? Or a coincidence? I didn't think about it. And then when you were like, I'm going to Joshua Tree for my birthday, and I realized I wore a Joshua Tree sweatshirt. I know. I feel like my celebration is starting. But yeah, my family, we're just going as a family to Joshua Tree for my milestone birthday. Beautiful state park.
我的意思是，等大家听到这期节目的时候，这事已经发生了。你今天穿着一件约书亚树国家公园的运动衫。那是为我的生日准备的吗？还是巧合？等大家听到这期节目的时候，这事已经发生了。你今天穿着一件约书亚树国家公园的运动衫。那是为我的生日准备的吗？还是巧合？我当时没多想。然后当你提到说，我要去约书亚树过生日时，我才意识到我穿了一件约书亚树运动衫。我知道。我觉得我的庆祝活动已经开始了。不过是的，我的家人，我们这次就是以家庭为单位去约书亚树过我的里程碑生日。美丽的州立公园。
I've never been. Oh, it's one of those places where you feel small in the world because it's just so beautiful and vast and you have to go stargazing. You see all the stars. There's no light pollution. I heard that. I wanted to go someplace majestic, someplace I've never been.
我从来没去过。哦，那是那种让你觉得自己在宇宙中十分渺小的地方，因为它实在是太美、太辽阔了，你必须去观星。你能看到所有的星星。那里没有任何光污染。我听说过这个。我想去一个宏伟的地方，一个我从未去过的地方。
And here it is. Joshua Tree is so close. I've lived out in LA more than 20 years and I've never gone to the desert. And Lee hired like a star expert person. A star expert person. That's what they're called. Yes, that's what's on their business card. Oh, that's going to be wonderful. Yeah. So one evening we're going to go out and they're going to tell us everything that's
然后它就在这儿。约书亚树离得这么近。我在洛杉矶住了二十多年，却从来没去过沙漠。而且李还雇了一个观星专家。观星专家。他们是这么叫的。对，他们的名片上就是这么写的。哦，那一定太棒了。对啊。所以有一天晚上我们要出去，他们会给我们讲解天空中
in the sky. And that's gonna be such a special birthday. You have to send me a picture. Oh, I will, of course. Well, guys, thank you. This was so awesome, and I can't wait to eat the sweet treats that you got. I know. Oh, yeah, we also got tiny desserts because Jenna loves tiny desserts.
所有的东西。那将会是一个非常特别的生日。你一定要发张照片给我。哦，我当然会。好了，伙计们，谢谢你们。这太棒了，我已经迫不及待想吃你们准备的甜点了我懂。哦，对了，我们还买了很多迷你甜点，因为珍娜喜欢迷你甜点。
We'll do that at break, and we also got flowers. This is amazing. And I'm excited to share my birthday with the episode today because it is one of my favorites. I think it's one of your funniest performances. I loved it so much. There's an episode coming up, I'm not even going to go there yet, that I think you should have won the Emmy for. I'm going to wait for that. Oh, my. But this is so funny. You and Kate Flannery are so funny.
我们会在休息时间吃，我们还买了花。这太棒了。我很兴奋能把我的生日和今天的剧集分享出去，因为这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我觉得这是你最搞笑的表演之一。我太喜欢了。有一集快要播出了，我甚至现在还不想剧透，我觉得你应该凭那一集赢得艾美奖。我要留到那时候再说。哦，天哪。但这太搞笑了。你和凯特·弗兰纳里太搞笑了。
Why are we so good in season nine, lady? You and I, we really are very, very good in this season. We're late. What are we, late bloomers? I guess so. Well, listen, today we are talking about Lice. It is season nine, episode 10, written by Nikki Schwartz-Wright and directed by Rodman Flender.
为什么我们在第九季表现得这么好，女士？你和我，在这个季度里真的非常非常棒。我们老了吗？我们是大器晚成吗？我想是的。好吧，听着，今天我们要聊的是《虱子》。这是第九季第10集，由尼基·施瓦茨-赖特编剧，罗德曼·弗兰德执导。
Here is your summary. With Jim away, Pam struggles to balance work and kids and accidentally infects the office with Cece's lice. But she lets Meredith take the fall. Meanwhile, Val breaks up with Daryl and Jim plays basketball with his idol. Are you ready for fast fact number one? Yeah. Fast fact number one is Meredith's bald head. Oh my gosh. We got a lot of mail. So much mail. Because in this episode, Meredith shaves her head. She finds out she has lice and she just shaves her head. Mm-hmm. I remember after the table read for this episode, we were all like, wait Kate can't shave her head. Yeah, how is that
以下是剧情简介。吉姆不在家，帕姆艰难地平衡着工作和孩子，不小心把西西的虱子传染给了办公室。但她让梅雷迪思背了黑锅。与此同时，瓦尔和达里尔分手了，吉姆则和他的偶像打篮球。你准备好听冷知识一号了吗？准备好了。冷知识一号是梅雷迪思的光头。哦天哪。我们收到了很多信。超级多的信。因为在这集里，梅雷迪思剃光了头。她发现自己长了虱子，然后就把头剃了。嗯-hmm。我还记得这集的围读剧本结束后，我们都在想，等等，凯特不能剃光头啊。对啊，那要怎么
gonna work? And my memory is that Greg originally wanted Kate to actually shave her head, like, in the episode, like, on camera. I kind of remember that too. And here's the thing, you guys. We have been waiting for so long to talk to Kate about this episode. It's one of her best performances.
行得通？我的记忆是，格雷格最初是想让凯特在剧里真的把头剃了，就像，在镜头前那样。我好像也记得是这样。事情是这样的，伙计们。我们等了这么久，就是为了跟凯特聊聊这一集。这是她最好的表演之一。
And I reached out to her, and she has wonderful things to share with us. This is one of our favorite Meredith storylines and Kate was so gracious and sent us such fun audio clips. Let's start with the question, did Greg ask you to shave your head, Kate? Hey, it's Kate. Yeah, I played Meredith on The Office. It's me, I swear to God. Okay, so lice. Is it true that Greg Daniels asked or assumed that I would shave my head? This is the deal. Greg asked if I would shave my head. Okay, he had this vision that was from the movie Full Metal Jacket where then all the soldiers are like shaving their heads,
我联系了她，她有很多精彩的见解要跟我们分享。这是我们最喜欢的梅雷迪思故事线之一，凯特非常大方，给我们发了这么有趣的音频片段。让我们从这个问题开始，格雷格要求你剃光头了吗，凯特？嘿，我是凯特。对，我在《办公室》里扮演梅雷迪思。真的是我，我发誓。好吧，关于虱子。格雷格·丹尼尔斯要求或者默认我会剃光头，这是真的吗？情况是这样的。格雷格问我愿不愿意剃光头。好吧，他当时有个构想，灵感来自电影《全金属外壳》，片中所有士兵都在剃光头，
the hair going everywhere. Yeah, so season one, Greg asked me to dress up like Madonna in the background of a cutaway photo of Michael Scott and Dwight dressed as Crockett in tubs from Miami Vice at an 80s party. And I said yes. He asked me if I would do an insert shot for the Fun Run episode where I get hit by the car where I actually hit the glass and roll off the top of the car and fall into the ground on a mat, but still. And I said yes. So Greg asked me if I'd shaved my head and I said, is there a plan B? And he said yes. He said that plan B was a bald cap. So I said, it's a really
头发到处飞。对，所以在第一季的时候，格雷格让我穿成麦当娜的样子，出现在迈克尔·斯科特和穿着迈阿密风云里克罗克特式白色西装的德怀特在80年代派对上的剪辑照片背景里。我答应了。他问我愿不愿意在《趣味长跑》那一集里拍一个特写镜头，就是我被车撞的那场戏，我真的撞到玻璃上，然后从车顶滚下来，掉在垫子上的那个，虽然那是垫子。我还是答应了。所以格雷格问我愿不愿意剃光头时，我说，有没有B计划？他说有。他说B计划是一个光头头套。所以我说，这是一个非常
big decision so I'm'm gonna sleep on it. So I emailed him first thing in the morning and I said, I pick plan B. Yeah, I would pick plan B too. I'm very glad she picked plan B. I mean, she mentioned a few things, but she didn't even mention having a warehouse shelf fall on her or the bat. The bat on her head.
重大的决定，我要考虑一晚。于是我第二天一早给他发邮件说，我选B计划。对，我也会选B计划。我很高兴她选了B计划。我的意思是，她提到了好几件事，但她甚至都没提过仓库货架砸到她身上，或者那只蝙蝠。蝙蝠落在他头上。
The show and the tatas. Flashing, yes. I mean, Kate has shown up for this role in so many ways. I think it's A-OK that she said, I don't want to shave my head. Yeah. Well, Kate ended up getting the bald cap for this episode and we asked her about what that process was like and here is what she said. Ed French is like the greatest bald cap for this episode and we asked her about what that process was like
演出和胸部。走光，是的。我的意思是，凯特为这个角色付出了太多。我觉得她说“我不想剃光头”是完全OK的。对啊。好吧，凯特最后为这一集准备了光头头套，我们问她这个过程是怎么样的，她是这么说的。爱德·弗朗西斯就像是世界上最棒的光头头套制作大师，这一集我们问她这个过程是怎么样的
and here is what she said. Ed French is like the greatest bald cap dude in the world. He teaches a lot of makeup artists how to do it. He did the bald cap for Star Trek the movie from like, is that from 1980? The bald lady who's not really bald now. I didn't know that. I thought she was bald. Ed did such a great job. He's amazing. And the process for the full bald cap was every day for a week. Actually, technically it was two weeks because there was another episode where I was wearing a wig and it falls off and I have a bald underneath. So we had two full weeks of this. Maybe not. No, maybe we can have. Okay. It was awful. That was great. It was fine. It was just a lot. A three and a half hours in and two hours out
她是这么说的。爱德·弗朗西斯就像是世界上最棒的光头头套制作大师。他教过很多化妆师怎么做这个。他制作了《星际迷航》电影中的光头头套，那是从什么时候开始的，是1980年的吗？那个光头女士现在其实不是光头的。我当时不知道。我还以为她是光头呢。爱德做得太棒了。他太厉害了。制作整个光头头套的过程是连续一周，每天都要弄。其实严格来说是两周，因为还有一集我戴着假发，假发掉下来，露出下面的光头。所以我们连续两周都在搞这个。也许不是。不，也许我们可以。好吧。太可怕了。那挺棒的。也还行。就是挺折腾的。进去折腾三个半小时，出来要两个小时
and they do this like thing, they literally sculpt your hair to fit your head. They just like swirl it around with this liquid. It's crazy, it's like a weird glue. It comes out, but it's like, whoa, it's intense. And then there's like wax and there's, and then he painted like blood vessels and like hair stubble. I mean this guy was an artist like unbelievable. He's like the king daddy.
他们会弄那种东西， literalmente 照着你的头型把你的头发塑形。他们会用这种液体把你的头发绕成一团。太疯狂了，就像一种奇怪的胶水。能弄下来，但感觉就是，哇，太强烈了。然后还有蜡什么的，接着他还在上面画了血管和发茬。我的意思是这家伙是个艺术家，简直不可思议。他就像是老大中的老大。
We would get there at 3 30 in the morning. You know I was a little younger then so whatever big whoop. Three and a half hours and she had to get there at 3.30 in the morning. And then it takes two hours to get out of it. And the glue and the wax and the, I mean, that is a journey, getting that bald cap on. So you know, lady, years later, when I was on Splitting Up Together, I had to get a bald cap. And it was the same guy, Ed French.
我们凌晨3点半就得到那儿。你知道那时候我还比较年轻，所以管他呢，多大点事。三个半小时，她得凌晨3点半到那儿。然后光是卸妆就要花两个小时。还有胶水、蜡，我的意思是，戴上那个光头头套简直是一场漫长的旅程。所以你知道吗，女士，多年后，我在拍《分道扬镳》时，我也得戴光头头套。而且是同一个人，爱德·弗朗西斯。
He's the dude. He's the guy. He came and did this same process to me and I remember reaching out to Kate and being like, guess who I'm with right now? Guess what's happening to me? And also she was like a person who knew what I was going through
他就是那个牛人。他就是那个家伙。他来对我重复了同样的制作流程，我记得我当时联系了凯特，对她说，你猜我现在跟谁在一起？你猜我正经历着什么？而且她是一个真正懂我当时感受的人
because she had done it. And she's like, doesn't your head get so cold when you get the, it is, it's like, it's like a glue, but it's not glue, but they have to put this stuff on your hair that like slicks it to your head so there's no bulges so that you have a perfectly round bald head when they put the bald cap on. But it's like, it takes so long because you have to do that
因为她也经历过。她说，你戴上那个的时候，头皮不觉得超级冷吗，就是那种感觉，就像是胶水，但又不是胶水，他们必须在你的头发上抹一种东西，把它紧紧贴在你的头上，这样才不会鼓包，当你戴上光头头套时，你才能拥有一个完美圆润的光头。但这很费时间，因为你必须先把这个做好
but then you have to wait. And then you have to do the next step and then you have to wait. And then he puts the do the next step, and then you have to wait. And then he puts the bald cap on, and then there's all this airbrushing and like detail makeup to make it look seamless. It was crazy. Here's the thing, on splitting up together,
然后你还得等。接着你得进行下一步，然后你还得等。然后他把光头头套戴上，接着还要进行各种喷枪上色和细节化妆，让它看起来天衣无缝。太疯狂了。事情是这样的，在拍《分道扬镳》的时候，
they cut the scene. Oh no, you went through all of that and they cut the scene? Yeah, can you even believe that? But anyway, I'll give you the pictures of me bald in my Ed French baldness. Oh, I'll do a side by side. You can do a side by side of me and Kate in our Ed French bald caps.
他们把那场戏给剪了。哦不，你经历了这一切，结果他们把戏给剪了？对，你敢相信吗？不过没关系，我会把我在爱德·弗朗西斯的巧手下变成光头的照片发给你。哦，我会做个对比图。你可以把我跟凯特戴着爱德·弗朗西斯制作的光头头套的照片做个对比。
I love it. Well, Kate, thank you so much. We're going to hear more from Kate as we break down this episode. Moving on to fast fact number two, big guest star cameo alert basketball legend, Dr. Julius Irving. Dr. J in the house.
我太喜欢了。好吧，凯特，非常感谢你。在我们剖析这一集的过程中，我们还会听到更多凯特的声音。接下来进入冷知识二号，重磅客串明星来袭，篮球传奇人物，朱利叶斯·欧文博士。J博士驾到。
For anyone who doesn't know, Dr. J won three NBA championships, four most valuable player awards, and three scoring titles with the Virginia Squires, New York Nets, who are now the Brooklyn Nets, and the Philadelphia 76ers, basketball legend on our show. When you watch this episode, if you think, gosh, the character Jim is so giddy around Dr. J,
对于任何不了解的人来说，J博士曾随弗吉尼亚绅士队、纽约网队（现为布鲁克林网队）和费城76人队赢得过三次NBA总冠军、四次最有价值球员奖和三次得分王称号，这位篮球传奇来到了我们的节目中。当你观看这一集时，如果你觉得，天哪，吉姆这个角色在J博士面前怎么这么晕乎陶醉，
that is just John Krasinski. He was giddy. He was so tickled to be in those scenes. Well, Angela, I remember that. So I reached out to John. Oh yeah, what do you say? Krasinski. He was giddy. He was so tickled to be in those scenes. Well, Angela, I remember that. So I reached out to John. Oh, yeah. What do you say? And I was like, John, do you have anything to say about working with Dr. J? And here's what he said. He said, I mean, it was Dr. J. Had a poster of him on my wall as a
那其实就是约翰·卡拉辛斯基本人。他当时就是晕乎乎的。能够参演那些场景让他兴奋不已。好吧，安吉拉，我还记得这事。所以我联系了约翰。哦对，他说什么来着？卡拉辛斯基。他当时就是晕乎乎的。能够参演那些场景让他兴奋不已。好吧，安吉拉，我还记得这事。所以我联系了约翰。哦对，他说什么来着？
kid. If you had told that kid that he would one day not only meet Dr. J, but pretend to have a fake business meeting with him on a television show. And get to shoot a basket with him. Well, that poor kid just blacked out. Yeah, he was so excited. Yeah. It was so cute.
我说，约翰，关于和J博士合作，你有什么想说的吗？他是这么说的。他说，我的意思是，那是J博士啊。我小时候墙上就贴着他的海报。如果你告诉那个小男孩，他有一天不仅能见到J博士，还能在电视剧里假装和J博士开个假商务会议。
I don't think he had to act at all in those scenes. Not for a second. No. We also got a fan question from William M. from, quote, all over the United States Air Force. How did you get Dr. J on the show? Well, William, Lauren Anderson, who was one of the executives at NBC,
还能跟他一起投个篮。好吧，那个可怜的小男孩当时直接当场晕厥了。对啊，他太兴奋了。对啊。太可爱了。
was our connection to Dr. J. Steve Burgess told me she helped to arrange his appearance. He was only available for one day that week. He's busy. Yeah, we flew him in. We arranged our whole schedule so that we could have him for that one day. Amazing.
我觉得他在那些场景里根本不需要演技。一秒钟都不用。没有。我们还收到了来自美国空军全体的威廉·M.的粉丝提问。你是怎么请到J博士上节目的？好吧，威廉，NBC的高管之一劳伦·安德森，
Well, Jenna, it's time for your fast fact number three. And I'm really hoping, you haven't told me, but I am really hoping that this is a deep dive on lice. Please tell me it is. Lady, it is your dream come true. Do I know you? I know you. We now know how each other preps an episode. You know it.
就是我们联系J博士的桥梁。史蒂夫·伯吉斯告诉我，她帮忙安排了这次出场。他那一周只有一天有空。他很忙。对啊，我们把他用飞机接来的。我们调整了整个日程，以便能邀请他来待那一天。太棒了。
Fast Fact 3 is lice trivia from Laurel M. in Woodstock, Georgia. Laurel, what do you have? Laurel is our deep dive expert on lice because Laurel wrote us a letter that says this, I am way more excited than I should be to write in about lice. However, seeing as that my family recently dealt with an infestation and my 12 year old had to watch
好吧，珍娜，轮到你的冷知识三号了。我真心希望——你还没告诉我呢——但我真心希望这是一个关于虱子的深度解析。请告诉我它是。女士，这绝对是梦想成真。我还不了解你吗？我太了解了。现在我们都知道彼此是怎么为一集节目做准备了。你懂的。
this episode while being lice checked, I feel it's appropriate. Here is what Laurel had to say. Lice fast facts. One, lice like clean scalps. Clean scalps. Yes. So in this episode, we're assuming that it was like, oh, Meredith never bathes. That's why she has lice. No, no, no. Lice like a clean scalp.
冷知识三是来自佐治亚州伍德斯托克的劳伦·M.提供的虱子冷知识。劳伦，你有什么料？劳伦是我们的虱子深度解析专家，因为劳伦给我们写了一封信，内容是这样的：对于写信聊虱子这件事，我的兴奋程度远远超出了正常范围。不过，鉴于我的家里人最近刚刚经历了一场虱子爆发，而且我12岁的孩子不得不一边被检查有没有虱子一边收看
Yeah. Greasy scalp they like slide off of or something. Oh. I mean, I don't know. I'm just like imagining little lice just like sliding off people's heads. Number two, lice cannot fly or jump. You have to really be close to someone. Lice have to like crawl into another person's head.
这一集，我觉得这很合情合理。劳伦是这么说的。关于虱子的冷知识。第一，虱子喜欢干净的头皮。干净的头皮。是的。所以在这一集里，我们原本以为剧情设定是，哦，梅雷迪思从来不洗澡。所以她才长了虱子。不，不，不。虱子喜欢干净的头皮。
Yeah. Okay. Laurel said gross. Yeah, that is gross. Number three, they can only infest your head. They can live in bedding or rug, clothing or fabric, but only for 24 hours. And lice cannot reproduce off the head. So if they get transferred to a hat,
对啊。油腻的头皮它们反而会滑下来什么的。哦。我的意思是，我不知道。我只是在想象小虱子从人们头上滑下来的样子。第二，虱子不会飞也不会跳。你必须离某人非常近才行。虱子必须爬到另一个人的头上。
they can't multiply unless they get back on a head. So gross. Also, I guess Meredith really didn't need to wax her pubic area for lice. She didn't want it to travel south. Here is lice fact number four. Have you heard of the blood rhesus factor? That's like where your blood type can determine
对啊。好吧，劳伦说这太恶心了。对，那确实很恶心。第三，它们只能寄生在你的头上。它们可以活在床单、地毯、衣服或织物里，但最多只能存活24小时。而且虱子离开头部后是无法繁殖的。所以如果它们转移到了帽子上，
certain things like, I don't know. I've heard of it loosely, but I guess it's true that lice prefer positive blood over negative blood types. But they will feed on either. However, lice can't like start on one blood type and move to another blood type. So if a louse is feeding on a person with A positive blood and then they end up getting transferred to a person with B negative blood, it won't live.
除非它们回到头上，否则它们是无法繁殖增多的。太恶心了。还有，我猜梅雷迪思其实根本没必要为了防虱子去给私处脱毛。她可不想让虱子往南边扩散。以下是虱子冷知识四。你听说过恒河猴因子（Rh因子）吗？就是那种你的血型可以决定
That is fascinating. Right? Yeah. Laurel, way to go Laurel. I know. Laurel said this proved true in my family because she said only the people with negative blood had lice and the people with positive blood did not get lice in her family. Oh man, this is so interesting.
某些事情，比如，我不知道。我隐约听说过，不过据说虱子确实比阴性血型更偏爱阳性血型。但它们不管什么血型都会吸血。不过，虱子不能从一种血型开始寄生然后转移到另一种血型。所以如果一只虱子在吸食一个A型阳性血的人的血，然后它最终转移到了一个B型阴性血的人身上，它是无法存活的。
Lice fact number five, you do not have to wash everything in your house like Pam did because lice cannot actually infest your whole house. You just have to wash your bed linens, any recently worn clothing, and put any like hair items like brushes, combs in the freezer and that's it. However, Laurel does recommend buying something called the Terminator comb, which is the only comb that will really rid your head of lice. And finally, Laurel says, as the lady was checking my 12-year-old's head
这太迷人了。对吧？对啊。劳伦，太棒了劳伦。我知道。劳伦说这在她家里得到了证实，因为她说她家里只有阴性血的人得了虱子，而阳性血的人没有得虱子。天哪，这太有趣了。
and she was watching the lice episode, Dwight has the line, I wash my hair every day with lice shampoo. And the lady looked at us and said, no, do not ever do that. Do not wash your hair with lice shampoo every day. And then Laurel says, and now you know more about lice than you ever thought you'd know. Well done, Laurel. Laurel.
虱子冷知识五，你不需要像帕姆那样把家里所有的东西都洗一遍，因为虱子实际上并不会侵扰你整个家。你只需要洗床单、任何最近穿过的衣服，然后把梳子、刷子之类的美发用品放进冰箱冷冻就行了，就这么简单。不过，劳伦确实推荐买一种叫“终结者梳”（Terminator comb）的东西，这是唯一真正能彻底清除你头上虱子的梳子。最后，劳伦说，当那位女士正在检查我12岁孩子的头部
Well done. This was, I don't even know what to say. I'm speechless. You have out deep dived me. I love it. I mean, not that I'm the deep dive expert, but wow,, I'm speechless. You have out deep dived me. I love it. I mean, not that I'm the deep dive expert, but wow, you really covered it. You did a great job.
而她当时正在看虱子那一集时，德怀特有句台词是：“我每天都用去虱洗发水洗头。”那位女士看着我们说：“不，千万别那么做。绝不要每天用去虱洗发水洗头。”然后劳伦说：“现在，你对虱子的了解比你想象的还要多了。”干得漂亮，劳伦。劳伦。
Yes. Finally, Angela, in our Fast Fact About Lice, we have a fan question from Isabella S. from Massachusetts. Have you or your kids ever had lice? Oh, gosh, Isabella. As Laurel was talking, I relived a whole week of my life. Okay, lice spread through third grade like wildfire when my daughter was in third grade. What is it about third grade? You know, this is the thing. Every year, the third grade, because our kids go to the same school. They have a lice infestation in the third grade. And I'm surprised to learn that lice cannot
干得漂亮。这简直，我都不知道该说什么了。我无言以对。你在深度解析上把我比下去了。我太喜欢了。我的意思是，倒不是说我是深度解析专家，但是哇，我无言以对。你在深度解析上把我比下去了。我太喜欢了。我的意思是，倒不是说我是深度解析专家，但是哇，你真的讲得太全面了。你做得太棒了。
live off the head because there's been... I swear that classroom has it. That's what we've all been saying. All the moms are like, watch out for third grade. The class has lice. Like before you even start school, just assume you're going to have a lice adventure. Well, we know who patient zero was. I won't say her name. And oh my gosh. So it's about was like kind of scratching her scalp. And I was like, what's going on? She's like, I don't know, I'm itchy. And I started to dig through her hair. And I was like, Oh, gosh, I see there's like a little thing moving. It freaked me out. Wow. I immediately texted the mom thread, right? And I'm like, Okay, does that one girl who left school, I mean, is it cause she has lice?
是的。最后，安吉拉，在我们的虱子冷知识里，有一个来自马萨诸塞州的伊abella S.的粉丝提问。你或你的孩子得过虱子吗？哦，天哪，伊abella。当劳伦在讲的时候，我简直像重新经历了我人生中的整整一周。好吧，当我的女儿上三年级时，虱子在三年级里像野火一样蔓延开来。三年级到底有什么魔咒？你知道吗，就是这样。每年三年级，因为我们的孩子在同一所学校。三年级的班级总会爆发虱子。我很惊讶地得知虱子竟然无法
And then someone else was like, I think so. And then we all started like finding out, where do you go? What do you do? There's a place that everyone goes to around here. The lice lady. The lice lady. And she uses these organic products.
离开头部生存，因为一直以来……我发誓那个教室绝对有虱子。我们所有人都是这么说的。所有的妈妈都在提醒：小心三年级。那个班有虱子。就像你开学前一样，直接默认你将要经历一场虱子大冒险。好吧，我们知道零号病人是谁了。我不会说出她的名字。哦天哪。所以当时她有点在抓头皮。我就问，怎么了？她说，我不知道，我好痒啊。然后我开始在她的头发里翻找，接着我说，哦，天哪，我看到有什么小东西在动。把我吓坏了。哇。我立刻在妈妈群里发了信息，对吧？我说，好吧，那个请假离校的女孩，我是说，是不是因为她长了虱子？
She goes through with that comb. She sent me home with a kit. Well, guess what? What? I had laid with Isabel until she fell these organic products. She goes through with that comb. She sent me home with a kit. Well, guess what? What? I had laid with Isabelle until she fell asleep that week. You know how you do. I like scratched her back. I fell asleep putting her to bed.
然后另一个人说，我想是的。接着我们所有人开始打听，你去哪里看？你该怎么办？这里每个人都会去一个地方。虱子夫人。虱子夫人。她用的是这些有机产品。
Of course. Yeah. Guess who else got lice? Oh my God. Me. And then Cade got it, cause Cade and Isabelle were watching a movie together. Wow.
她用那把梳子仔细梳理。她让我带了一套工具回家。好吧，你猜怎么着？什么？我陪着伊abelle直到她睡着。这些有机产品。她用那把梳子仔细梳理。她让我带了一套工具回家。好吧，你猜怎么着？什么？那一周我一直陪着伊abelle直到她睡着。你知道的，就像你平时做的那样。我拍着她的背。结果我哄她睡觉自己却睡着了。
Jack and Drosh did not get it. Me and Cade and Isababel are all positive blood types. What? Yes, and I didn't know that till you just said that. That is crazy. Yeah, it was a whole thing. I did wash everything in the house, just like Pam. I like washed everything. And then we would braid our hair. We put the spray on it after we'd washed it. This like organic, like spray this lady gave us. I'll never forget, I had to run an errand and I ran into a mom from the school and I had my hair in that greasy slick braid
当然啦。对啊。你猜谁也染上虱子了？天哪。我。然后凯德也染上了，因为凯德和伊abelle一起看电影来着。哇。
they tell you to do, the lice lady told me to do. And I knew the mom knew I had it. And I still think about it. She was like, oh, that's an interesting way to wear your hair. That's what she said to me. And I was like, yeah, I just thought, you know what? I don't feel like dealing with it today, but I knew she knew and she knew, I knew she knew.
杰克和德罗什没得。我和凯德还有伊abelle全都是阳性血型。什么？是的，在你刚才说之前我都不知道这件事。这太疯狂了。对啊，那真是一场折腾。我确实把家里所有的东西都洗了一遍，就像帕姆那样。我把所有东西都洗了。然后我们还会把头发编成辫子。洗完头后我们在上面喷喷雾。就是那个女人给我们的一种有机喷雾。我永远不会忘记，有一次我得出去跑腿，结果碰到了学校的一个妈妈，当时我的头发梳成了那种他们叫你梳的油腻紧绷的辫子，
Oh my gosh. Well, you know, when it was time for my son to be in third grade, guess what happened? Pandemic. Oh. He never set foot in the third grade classroom. And guess what? His class never got lice. Oh really. And guess what? His class never got lice. Oh, really?
虱子夫人让我梳的那种。我知道那个妈妈看出我得虱子了。我到现在还经常想起这事。她当时说：“哦，你这个发型梳得真有意思。”她当时就是这么对我的。我心想，好吧，我当时只觉得，你知道吗？我今天实在懒得应付这事了，但我知道她知道，她也知道我知道她知道。
Mm-hmm. And guess what? My daughter went through third grade classroom. Lice. We didn't get it, but lice. Oh. Third grade classroom has lice right now! Are you serious?
哦天哪。好吧，你知道吗，到了我儿子该上三年级的时候，你猜发生什么了？大流行。哦。他压根没踏进过三年级教室一步。你猜怎么着？他的班级从来没得过虱子。哦真的吗。你猜怎么着？他的班级从来没得过虱子。哦，真的吗？
Yes, I just got a text. What the heck? Beware, third grade has lice. They need to get that Dwight bomb and set it off in there. I guess so. Oh my goodness. All right. That was a long top of show, folks.
嗯-hmm。你猜怎么着？我女儿上三年级的时候。虱子。我们虽然没得，但是虱子来了。哦。三年级教室现在正闹虱子呢！你认真的吗？
Yes. But we had a lot to talk about, a lot to do. Let's take a break. And when we get back, we will start going through this episode like a lice comb. Oh, let's not go through it like a lice comb. I can find lice on your head, by the way. It's now a skill I have. I know where to look.
是的，我刚收到一条短信。搞什么鬼？小心，三年级闹虱子了。他们得把德怀特那个去虱烟雾弹拿去在那里引爆。我看也是。哦天哪。好了。开场白聊得够久了，各位。
The lady showed me how to do it. They love the back of your hairline, and back behind your ear. Why am I making that noise? Should you do? I'm all braggy. I'll check your head for lice. If I ever need a lice check,
是的。但我们有太多话要说，有太多事要做。我们休息一下。等我们回来，我们将像用密齿去虱梳一样仔仔细细地剖析这一集。哦，可别像去虱梳那样剖析它。顺便说一句，我能在你头上找到虱子。这现在是我掌握的一项技能了。我知道该去哪找。
I'll just come to your place. Call me. Call me. We are back, and this time you're the one who's eating, lady. I'm always eating. I got a piece of my tiny cake out there. I love it. It's very good. So sorry.
那个女士教过我怎么弄。它们喜欢你发际线的后方，还有耳朵后面。我为什么发出这种声音？你应该吗？我太爱显摆了。我会帮你检查头上有没有虱子。如果我什么时候需要检查虱子，
All right. I have some call sheet tidbits for you before we break down this episode. Oh, I love a call sheet tidbit. We started filming this episode on Monday, November 5th, 2012. The high that day, you know I love a weather report. The high that day was 90 degrees and by the time in November in November Right Wow and by the time we wrapped this episode on Friday, November 9th The high was only 63 degrees. Oh, it was that time of year
我直接去你家找你。给我打电话。给我打电话。我们回来了，这一次吃东西的是你哦，女士。我一直在吃。我刚刚在那里拿了一块我的迷你蛋糕。我太喜欢了。非常好吃。非常抱歉。
Yeah in LA in the winter were also the summer for a few days and everyone gets a cold bug Mm-hmm because the weather swings a few days. And everyone gets a cold bug, because the weather swings. So extreme. Big temperature, yeah. Also on the very first day of filming, they scheduled a test of the bald cap slash shaving rig with Kate, but we did not film that scene when she shaves her head until the final day on Friday.
好了。在剖析这一集之前，我有一些通告单（call sheet）的花絮要分享给你们。哦，我最喜欢通告单花絮了。我们是在2012年11月5日星期一开始拍摄这一集的。那天最高气温——你知道我最爱天气预报了——那天最高气温是90华氏度（约32摄氏度），然而到了11月，在11月。对啊。哇。等我们在11月9日星期五拍完这一集时，最高气温只有63华氏度（约17摄氏度）。哦，那正是那种季节。
And then, you know, they love to decorate our call sheets, and on Tuesday, the call sheets had little American flags and balloons and a bald eagle because it was Super Tuesday and everyone was voting. Lady, it's Super Tuesday today. I know. We're recording this on Super Tuesday. I know. That's so crazy.
对啊，洛杉矶的冬天有时候也会热上几天，然后每个人都会染上感冒。嗯-hmm。因为气温骤变。每个人都会感冒，因为天气波动太剧烈了。温差太大了，对。此外，在拍摄的第一天，他们安排了凯特进行光头头套/剃头装置的测试，但我们直到星期五最后一天才真正拍摄她剃头的那个场景。
Isn't that crazy? Yeah. Are we in the Matrix? I don't know. I'm wearing a Joshua Tree sweatshirt that I didn't even think about and you're going there? What's happening? What's happening? The coincidence is today. Let's hope no one gets lice.
然后呢，你知道他们很喜欢装饰我们的通告单，星期二的通告单上有小小的美国国旗、气球和一只秃鹰，因为那天是超级星期二（Super Tuesday），所有人都去投票了。女士，今天是超级星期二。我知道。我们是在超级星期二录音的。我知道。这太疯狂了。
There's a glitch in The Matrix. I don't know. Well listen, this episode is going to open with a little scene in the break room. It's just Jim and Daryl and Kevin and they're kind of arguing about basketball and Jim keeps biting his lip. Oh and he does that thing that you do, you know, when you bite your lip and then it makes a bump and then you keep biting the bump. You bite the bump. Did you notice Jim John's baby carrots? I sure did. I called them Jim John's baby carrots because it's really John that likes to eat the baby carrots as Jim. Jim John's baby carrots because it's really John that likes to eat the baby carrots as Jim. Jim John's baby carrots.
是不是超疯狂？对啊。我们是在母体（Matrix）里吗？我不知道。我穿着一件我根本没多想的约书亚树运动衫，而你正要去那里？这到底是怎么回事？发生什么事了？今天的巧合也太多了吧。希望没人长虱子。
Angela, we got a fan question for you. From Lee M. in San Jose. On the Blu-ray for this episode, there is a deleted scene for a cold open where the group discovers Creed's map to the office. Was this shot as an alternate cold open or was the cold open where Jim Bytes' lip planned for another episode? What's going on? All right, Lee, I have all the answers for you. So Jim biting his tongue was originally the cold open for Dwight's Christmas. Oh yeah, remember when we... Sorry, my mouth is full of cake. Oh yes, but then Dwight's Christmas has no cold open, no credits.
母体出故障了。我不知道。好吧，听着，这一集开场是休息室的一个小场景。只有吉姆、达里尔和凯文，他们似乎在争论篮球，而吉姆一直在咬嘴唇。哦，他做了那个你也会做的动作，你知道的，当你咬了嘴唇，然后嘴唇上起了一个小疙瘩，接着你就不停地去咬那个疙瘩。你去咬那个疙瘩。你注意到吉姆/约翰的胡萝卜小零食了吗？我当然注意到了。我管它们叫吉姆/约翰的胡萝卜小零食，因为实际上是约翰自己喜欢以吉姆的身份吃胡萝卜小零食。吉姆/约翰的胡萝卜小零食。吉姆/约翰的胡萝卜小零食。
Right, you commented on that right away. You're like, did you notice there's no cold open? There was, they just didn't include it. And yes, Lee, there's this whole storyline about Creed and his map. It's really funny. It was cut, but I guess you can still see it in the deleted scenes on the DVD and on the Blu-ray disc. Here's how it read in the shooting draft, and it was the cold open.
安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝提问是给你的。来自圣何塞的李·M.。在本集的蓝光光碟里，有一个关于冷开场的被删片段，讲的是大家发现了克里德办公室地图。这原本是作为备用冷开场拍摄的，还是说吉姆咬嘴唇那个冷开场原本是为另一集计划的？这到底是怎么回事？好吧，李，我来为你解答所有疑问。吉姆咬舌头这一段最初其实是《德怀特的圣诞节》的冷开场。哦对，还记得我们……抱歉，我嘴里塞满了蛋糕。哦是的，不过后来《德怀特圣诞节》没有冷开场，也没有片头字幕。
Okay. Interior break room day, Darryl, Pam, Phyllis, Oscar, and Toby are gathered around a large piece of paper on the break room table. There's a secretive vibe. The camera pushes in on the paper. It's a hand drawn map. The group all look at the map. Darryl says, maybe it's a shopping list?
对，你马上就指出来了。你当时说：“你注意到没有冷开场？”确实有，他们只是没把这段剪进去。没错，李，这里还有一条关于克里德和他的地图的完整剧情线。非常搞笑。它被删了，不过我想你仍然可以在DVD和蓝光光碟的被删片段里看到它。拍摄初稿里的内容是这样的，它原本就是冷开场。
Phyllis says, but what, he's buying a ham, a skeleton, and a mustache? A moustache. A moustache. Daryl says, it's Creed. And then Pam has a talking head, and she says, we found this weird drawing under Creed's desk. She shows us the drawing. There are waves, there's a bucket, a skeleton, a ham, straight lines separating them. It's a very simple maze. A few X's and some arrows. Pam goes,
好的。内景，休息室，日景。达里尔、帕姆、菲利斯、奥斯卡和托比聚集在休息室桌子上一大张纸周围。气氛很神秘。镜头推向那张纸。那是一张手绘地图。大家都在看着地图。达里尔说：“也许这是张购物清单？”
bizarre, huh? She shows the diagram to camera, then looks at it and turns at 90 degrees and goes, oh my god. Pam bursts back into the break room where the previous group are still lounging and says, it's a map. And they all say, what? And then they all figure out who they are on the map. It's really funny. So it's like a map of the office and then all the people are represented on the map.
菲利斯说：“但为什么，他在买火腿、骷髅头和八字胡？”八字胡。八字胡。达里尔说：“这可是克里德。”然后帕姆有一个单人访谈，她说：“我们在克里德的桌子底下发现了这个奇怪的画。”她向我们展示了那张画。上面有波浪线、一个水桶、一个骷髅头、一块火腿，还有把它们隔开的直线。这是一个非常简单的迷宫。几个叉号和一些箭头。帕姆说：
Angela is the skeleton. And Toby is the toilet. Wow. Daryl is a cheeseburger. Wow. I know. But it is on the DVDs. So there you go, Lee.
“太离谱了吧？”她把图表对着镜头展示了一下，然后看着它，把它转了90度，接着说：“哦，天哪。”帕姆冲回休息室，刚才那群人还在那里闲逛，她说道：“这是一张地图。”大家异口同声地问：“什么？”然后他们都在地图上找到了自己对应的位置。真的超级搞笑。这就像是一张办公室地图，然后所有人都被画在了地图上。
Amazing. Great question, great answer. So this is how the episode actually starts. A person comes into the office. They're in a coat. They have a hat kind of pulled down. They look a little ragged. And Erin says, oh, good morning, Meredith.
安吉拉是那个骷髅头。而托比是马桶。哇。达里尔是个汉堡包。哇。我知道。不过这确实收录在DVD里了，所以就是这样，李。
And it's Pam. It's Pam. Yeah, there's a talking head where Pam reveals that Jim has been spending a few nights a week in Philly. And it's been challenging. And we see a montage of Pam sort of trying to take out the trash, and things are falling everywhere. And then she shares that her current
太棒了。好问题，好回答。所以这一集实际上是这样开场的。一个人走进了办公室。穿着外套。帽子拉得很低。看起来有点衣衫褴褛。艾琳说：“哦，早安，梅雷迪思。”
problem is that Cece has lice and she was up all night. Yeah, she was disinfecting the entire house and then she says, don't tell Jim. He has a really big meeting today and he's doing it for the family. Like she doesn't want to stress him out with this. Lady, we got fan mail. Oh, yeah. Very passionate fan mail from Erin S. in Baltimore, Maryland. Here is what Erin had to say. Years. I have waited years to finally get up on my soapbox about this episode. Oh wow, let's hear it. I know Erin's coming in hot, huh? Yeah, she's hot to trot. She is. Here's what she goes on to say. While I have plenty of thoughts on the entire Jim Philly storyline, my biggest peccadillo about the whole thing is how Pam is portrayed in this episode.
结果是帕姆。是帕姆。是的，有一个单人访谈，帕姆在访谈中透露吉姆每周要在费城过夜几个晚上。这挺不容易的。我们看到一个蒙太奇镜头，帕姆试图拿倒垃圾，结果东西掉得到处都是。然后她分享说，她目前的
Pam is a strong, independent woman, a mother of two, a professional. She is fully capable of caring for her children on her own. She did just fine while Jim was in Tallahassee. Do you like the tone I'm taking to read the letter? I do, it's a Piccadillo. It's a Piccadillo. I'll go on.
问题是西西长了虱子，她一整夜没合眼。对啊，她一直在给整个房子消毒，然后她说：“别告诉吉姆。他今天有个非常重要的会议，他这么做是为了这个家。”她不想因为这些事给他增加压力。女士，我们收到粉丝来信了。哦，耶。来自马里兰州巴尔的摩的艾琳·S.发来的非常热情的粉丝来信。艾琳是这么说的。多年来。我等了好多年，终于能在这个问题上站上我的道德制高点来评判一番了。哦哇，我们听听看。我知道艾琳来势汹汹，对吧？对啊，她迫不及待了。确实。接着她是这么说的。虽然我对整个吉姆/费城的故事线有很多看法，但我对整件事最大的微词在于帕姆在这集里的塑造方式。
Pam and Jim both work full-time, so her children obviously have a well-established daycare situation going on, and her mother is staying with her to help. The idea that she would be so overwhelmed by being home alone with her children for a few days, that she would show up to work with unbrushed hair and a Miss Button sweater is just insulting
帕姆是一个坚强、独立的女性，两个孩子的母亲，一个职场人。她完全有能力独自照顾自己的孩子。就在吉姆在塔拉哈西的时候，她也把这一切处理得很好。你喜欢我读这封信时的语气吗？喜欢，这算是个“微词”。这算是个微词。我接着读。
to moms everywhere who routinely hold down the fort with grace and panache. A Piccadillo and a panache. I'm telling you, Erin. Erin, this is your soapbox moment. This is it. I'm doing my best to give it all I got. Two, there's more. Erin says, sure, she would be more tired. And Lice throws a wrench in the gears, but I cannot imagine any mother anywhere showing
帕姆和吉姆都是全职工作，所以她的孩子们显然有着非常稳定的日托安排，而且她的母亲也留下来帮她。那种认为她仅仅因为独自在家带几天孩子就会崩溃，以至于顶着一头没梳的头发、穿着纽扣掉了一半的毛衣去上班的说法，简直是对
up to work like that, no matter how rough their night was. After all the personal growth we've seen in Pam over the years, I just hated to see her presented as so helpless without her husband. how rough their night was. After all the personal growth we've seen in Pam over the years, I just hated to see her presented as so helpless without her husband. And then Erin signs off by saying, dismounts soapbox. Sets aside for Angela in a few episodes. Oh, so Erin, I'll be looking for that letter. I have a feeling I know which episode too. We got another letter that I'm calling, Counterpoint. Oh. This is from Kiana R. in Williams, Georgia, who said,
天下所有妈妈的侮辱，因为妈妈们通常都能优雅从容地把家里打理得井井有条。既有微词又有风度。我跟你说，艾琳。艾琳，这就是你的高谈阔论时刻。就是这样。我正竭尽全力把它读好。第二，还有更多。艾琳说：当然，她会更累一点。虱子确实打乱了阵脚，但无论前一晚有多艰难，我绝不相信任何母亲会顶着那副尊容去上班。在见证了帕姆多年来的个人成长之后，我真的讨厌看到她被描绘成一个离了丈夫就如此无助的形象。无论前一晚有多艰难，我绝不相信任何母亲会顶着那副尊容去上班。在见证了帕姆多年来的个人成长之后，我真的讨厌看到她被描绘成一个离了丈夫就如此无助的形象。最后，艾琳以这样的话结尾：从道德制高点下来。留给安吉拉在接下来的几集里评判。哦，所以艾琳，我会等着看那封信的。我有预感我也知道是哪一集。我们还收到了另一封信，我称之为“反观点”。哦。这是来自佐治亚州威廉斯的基安娜·R.写的，她说：
when my husband leaves me with the kids for several days, I feel like I'm going to die. LOL. I felt you portrayed so well the exhausted desperation of a mother doing it all on her own when she normally has help. Well, Angela, I thought I'd open it up. What do we think?
当我的丈夫把我和孩子们单独留下好几天时，我觉得自己快要死掉了。笑死。我觉得你们非常完美地展现了一个平时有人帮忙、但现在孤立无援的母亲那种精疲力竭、陷入绝望的状态。好吧，安吉拉，我想我们来讨论一下。大家怎么看？
Are we with Erin? Are we with Kiana? Are we somewhere in the middle? Where are we? I mean... listen. I think I'm with Erin. You're with Erin. I'm with Erin. I mean, you know, I was a single mom for a few years. And I had to get shit done. Yeah. I might with Erin. I mean, you know, I was a single mom for a few years
我们站在艾琳这边吗？还是站在基安娜这边？还是折中？我们到底站哪边？我是说……听着。我觉得我站艾琳这边。你站艾琳这边。我站艾琳这边。我是说，你知道的，我当了几年的单亲妈妈。我必须把事情搞定。对啊。我觉得我站艾琳这边。我是说，你知道的，我当了几年的单亲妈妈
and I had to get done. Yeah. I might not have had the cutest hairdo when I showed up to work, but I still showed up and I had everything done. So I guess I also do really hear Kiana too. I mean, I probably didn't look super put together, but I was able to take out the trash
我必须把事情搞定。对啊。我上班的时候发型可能不是最好看的，但我还是去上班了，而且所有事情我都处理好了。所以我想我也确实很能理解基安娜。我是说，我看起来可能确实没那么精致，但我还是能把垃圾桶搬到街上去
without spilling it into the street. Whatever. That moment was ridiculous to me. I'm like, Pam can put the trash bin on the street without tipping it over. She's not that tired. I guess now as I talk it out, I see both sides, but I think I lean more to Erin. That's very interesting. I hadn't even considered Erin's point of view on this until I read the letter. And I saw there was a lot of value in that letter. But I will tell you, I am a Kiana.
而不会把垃圾洒满整条街。管他呢。那个镜头在我看来简直荒谬。我想说，帕姆绝对有能力把垃圾桶推到街上而不把它弄翻。她没那么累。现在我想通了，我两边都能理解，但我还是更倾向于艾琳。这太有意思了。在读这封信之前，我甚至都没考虑过艾琳的观点。而且我发现这封信很有价值。但我得告诉你，我其实是个基安娜。
OK, I can completely fall apart when Lee leaves town. I have been Pam trying to take the trash out. OK, I don't take the trash out in my family, ever, ever. We have a running joke when my husband goes out of town I will send him a photo of our kitchen trash can like overflowing and I'll be like it's broken Usually I throw the trash and it disappears. I don't know where it goes It's always ready for me to use like the trash cans broken, babe Because he is trash guy and there's other things he does too. I don't know how we've done this division of labor
好吧，李离开镇上时，我整个人会彻底崩溃。我一直在扮演试图倒垃圾的帕姆。好吧，在我们家里，我从来、从来不倒垃圾。我们有个经常开的玩笑，当我老公出差时，我会给他发一张我们厨房垃圾桶的照片，里面满满当当的，我会说，它坏了。通常我扔了垃圾，它就自动消失了。我不知道它去哪儿了，它总是随时准备好让我用，就像垃圾桶坏了一样，宝贝。因为他是倒垃圾的人，他还会干别的。我不知道我们是怎么把劳动分工成这样的
almost unspoken. I mean, as far as he's concerned, the refrigerator cleans itself. I don't think he's ever thrown out a rotten piece of anything in the fridge. That's me, somehow we have these jobs. And I don't know. I have accidentally tried to take two cans to the curb
简直是不言而喻的。我的意思是，在他看来，冰箱自己会清洁。我觉得他从来没扔过冰箱里任何腐烂的东西。那都是我，不知怎么的，我们就有了这些分工。我也不知道。我有一次不小心试图把两个垃圾桶推到路边
at the same time and one falls over. I'm a mess when Lee leaves. I am. I'm a grumpy mess. I'm overwhelmed. My balance is all off. You did call me because the lights went out in your house and Lee was out of town. He was skiing with your son and you're like, and the power went out. And I was like, okay, well, I was like, someone needs to know. It's all good. Do you need me to come over? No, I'm a mess. I am a mess. So I guess I felt like Pam was me when Lee goes out of town.
同时推，结果一个倒了。李不在的时候我真是一团糟。我是真的。我成了一个暴躁的烂摊子。我不知所措。我的平衡感全失。你确实给我打过电话，因为你家里停电了，而李不在镇上。他和你的儿子去滑雪了，然后你说，电力系统瘫痪了。我说，好吧，嗯，我想，得有人知道这事。一切都好。你需要我过去吗？不，我一团糟。我真是一团糟。所以我想我觉得帕姆就像李不在镇上的我。
And I try to do what she does where I try to be like, no, no, it's all good here. Nothing to worry about. I'm not falling apart with trash on the street. It's all good. So that was a very honest performance for you. For me it was, yes. Yeah, I think I'm more Erin. You are more Erin.
我试着像她那样做，假装一切都好，这里什么事都没有。没有什么好担心的。我不会因为街上有垃圾而崩溃。一切都好。所以对你来说，那是一场非常诚实的表演。对我来说是的。是啊，我想我更像艾琳。你更像艾琳。
Jim is now gonna have a talking head. He shares that he's meeting his personal hero today, Dr. J, AKA Julius Irving, but he can't rub it in Pan's face because that would be like if he was home with the kids and she was out like go-karting with, I don't know, John Stamos. That's such a funny line.
吉姆现在要面对镜头说内心独白了。他分享说他今天见到了他的个人偶像J博士，也就是朱利乌斯·欧文，但他不能在帕姆面前显摆，因为那就像他带孩子在家，而她出去和——我不知道，约翰·斯坦莫斯去卡丁车赛场一样。这台词太搞笑了。
It's so specific. We got a fan question from Annem in Florida who said, go-karting with John Stamos is one of the funniest lines in this episode. Were there any alts? I feel like if there were, I'd love to hear. There were. Yeah, I mean, I know this was the scripted talking head,
太具体了。我们收到了来自佛罗里达州安姆的粉丝提问，她说，和约翰·斯坦莫斯一起开卡丁车是这集中最搞笑的台词之一。还有别的备选台词吗？我觉得如果有的话，我很想听听。有的。是的，我的意思是，我知道这是剧本写好的独白，
but I did not remember that there were alts. There were a few alts and I'll share one with you. So everything is the same except instead of John Stamos, they would just rotate in different names. Oh, here's one. Jim would have said, this would be like if Pam got to spend the day with Banksy. I think he's a person, right? Well, I thought that this talking head was very funny because I have another splitting up together story. I guess that's what this episode is about for me. When I worked on splitting up together, it was on the lot, the Warner Brothers lot.
但我完全不记得还有备选台词。确实有几句备选，我跟你们分享一句。所以一切都一样，除了不用约翰·斯坦莫斯，他们会换成不同的名字。哦，这里有一个。吉姆会说，这就好像帕姆能和班克西一起度过一天。我想他是个真人，对吧？好吧，我觉得这段独白非常搞笑，因为我有另一个关于分手的个人故事。我想这就是这一集对我来说的意义。当我参与《分分合合》时，它是在片场拍的，华纳兄弟的片场。
It's a huge lot. It's like a small city. Very, very big. And our dressing rooms that we were assigned, there are these buildings with dressing rooms. It's very like old Hollywood sort of. It's like the old studio days. Yes. Fascinating. It was very fun to shoot there. So our building with our dressing rooms was very far away from our soundstage.
这是一个巨大的片场。就像一个小城市。非常非常大。我们被分配到的化妆间，那些建筑里都有化妆间。非常有老好莱坞的感觉。就像过去的制片厂时代。是的。太迷人了。在那里拍摄非常有趣。所以我们化妆间的建筑离我们的摄影棚非常远。
And they would have to drive us around in little golf carts to get us there in a timely manner. But also there was like a commissary, a restaurant, there was a little gift shop that my kids would go to and I would buy them candy if they visited me. The Sony studio is the same way. When I did that show, Your Family or Mine, it was, you and I had never filmed on a big studio lot. No. So it was so interesting. There's like a gym. Yes. There's like a gym. Yes. There's like a little
他们不得不开着小高尔夫球车载我们过去，好让我们及时赶到。但那里也有小卖部、餐馆，还有一个小礼品店，我的孩子们去那里时，我会给他们买糖果。索尼片场也是这样。当我拍那部剧《你的还是我的》时，你和我从来没有在一个大型制片厂片场拍过戏。没有。所以太有趣了。那里有个健身房。是的。那里有个健身房。是的。还有个小
market store. So I asked, could I rent a little golf cart for myself and have my own little golf cart so that I could get around and like go to the little coffee place or get myself to set or or do these things. And they said, no. Actors were prohibited from having their own golf carts or scooters. Why? Because of John Stamos. What? Yes. What? What'd he do? Like, he got everyone banned? Yes. All actors banned? Yes. And I feel okay telling this story because I ran into him at a party Yes, and I feel okay telling this story because I ran into him at a party after this and I was like, John, you are why I couldn't have a golf cart at Warner Brothers. And he goes, I know, I'm so sorry. What? I don't know.
便利店。所以我问，我能为自己租一辆小高尔夫球车，拥有一辆自己的小高尔夫球车，这样我就可以到处走动，比如去小咖啡馆，或者去片场，或者做这些事情。他们说，不。演员被禁止拥有自己的高尔夫球车或滑板车。为什么？因为约翰·斯坦莫斯。什么？是的。什么？他干了什么？比如，他害得所有人都被禁了？是的。所有演员都被禁了？是的。我觉得讲这个故事没问题，因为我在一个派对上碰到了他。是的，我觉得讲这个故事没问题，因为我在一个派对上碰到了他，我说，约翰，就是因为你，我才不能在华纳兄弟拥有一辆高尔夫球车。他说，我知道，我太抱歉了。什么？我不知道。
I guess they shot full house there or something or maybe Fuller house. I'm not sure which one, but I guess he would zip around in the little golf carts or on the little scooters and they were like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Somehow him zipping around got us all banned from being able to use any mode of like self transport on the Warner Brothers lot. Lady, just the way he reacted, like, I know it's not just for zipping around. I don't know. I don't know. But he was like, I'm so sorry's not just for zipping around. I don't know, I don't know, but he was like,
我猜他们在那儿拍过《欢乐满屋》之类的情景喜剧，或者可能是《欢乐再满屋》。我不确定是哪一部，但我猜他会骑着小高尔夫球车或小滑板车四处飞驰，然后他们就受够了，不不不不不不不不。不知何故，他四处飞驰的行为导致我们所有人都被禁止在华纳兄弟片场使用任何自主交通工具。天哪，就他那个反应，就像是，我知道这不仅仅是因为到处瞎转悠。我不知道。我不知道。但他说，我很抱歉，不仅仅是因为到处瞎转悠。我不知道，我不知道，但他当时说，
I'm so sorry, I think they were having races. I bet he tipped one over or something. Maybe, I don't know, I don't know all the details. Maybe I'll run into him again and I'll get a refresher, but we had a good laugh about it. John, we want the full scoop about you getting everyone banned from having golf carts. I'm the Warner Brothers lot, but it made me laugh
我很抱歉，我想他们当时在比赛。我敢打赌他翻过一辆车什么的。也许吧，我不知道，我不知道所有细节。也许我下次还会遇到他，我会重新了解一下，但我们对此笑得很开心。约翰，我们想要知道你害得所有人都在华纳兄弟片场被禁止开高尔夫球车的内幕，但这也逗笑了我
because, you know, go-karting, golf-karting, just the idea of zipping around with John Stamos, it holds water. There's some reality there. He would do that. Well, this Pam and Jim phone call wraps up. They both kind of lie to each other. Like, Pam's like, I'm doing great. And Jim's like, oh, my taxi's here, but it's actually a limo.
因为，你知道的，开卡丁车、开高尔夫球车，一想到和约翰·斯坦莫斯四处狂飙的画面，这事就说得通。里面有那么点现实基础。他确实会这么干。好了，帕姆和吉姆的这通电话快结束了。他们俩都有点在对对方撒谎。比如，帕姆说，我过得挺好的。而吉姆说，哦，我的出租车到了，但实际上那是一辆豪华轿车。
And he's really excited, but he's downplaying that. So you're already kind of seeing a disconnect, how they're not really sharing about what's really going on in their lives. Yeah, they think that they're kind of protecting one another. In Pam's case, she's being supportive of him by not weighing him down with the day to day. And Jim feeling like he's not making her feel bad about not having new things in her life. Mm-hmm. Well, now we're gonna move to the parking lot for our Daryl and Val storyline.
他真的很兴奋，但他表现得很低调。所以你已经能看出某种脱节，他们并没有真正分享各自生活中真正发生的事情。是的，他们以为自己在某种程度上是在保护对方。对帕姆来说，她没有用日常琐事去拖累他，以此来支持他。而吉姆觉得他不想让她因为生活里没有新鲜事而感到难过。嗯哼。好吧，现在我们要转到停车场，来看看我们的达里尔和瓦尔的故事线。
I titled this storyline, WTF Daryl. Oh, we got so much mail about her. I don't understand. He was so excited. He liked her so much. And now there's a job in Philly, and he's like, I don't wanna be tied down. Buh-bye.
我给这条故事线取名为：达里尔，搞什么鬼。哦，我们收到了好多关于她的邮件。我不明白。他之前那么兴奋。他那么喜欢她。现在费城有个工作机会，而他说，我不想被拴住。拜拜。
Guess who agrees with you? Jennifer P from Spanaway, Washington. Thank you, Jennifer. Jennifer says, what's up with Daryl in the sudden 180 with Val? After working so hard to form a relationship with Val, now he's suddenly behaving as if she's a bother? It was just a few episodes ago
猜猜谁跟你的看法一样？来自华盛顿州斯潘韦的詹妮弗·P。谢谢你，詹妮弗。詹妮弗说，达里尔对瓦尔的态度怎么突然来了一百八十度大转弯？在费了那么大劲跟瓦尔建立关系之后，他现在怎么突然表现得好像她是个累赘？就在几集前
that he and Val posed hand in hand in a photo with Jada. With his daughter! Yes, Jennifer! They took basically a family photo. Yep, we hear you. Yeah, Darryl is doing that thing where he has an opportunity and he's doing that thing where he thinks like his whole life is going to change or has to change because of this one new opportunity. But then all that happens is you're going to like move to to change because of this one new opportunity.
他和瓦尔在一张照片里手挽着手和杰达一起合影。带着他的女儿！是的，詹妮弗！他们基本上拍了一张全家福。是的，我们听到你的心声了。是的，达里尔在做那种事，他得到了一个机会，然后他脑子一热，觉得因为这一个新机会，他整个人生都要改变了，或者必须改变。但接下来发生的一切只是你要搬去费城，而且生命中没有爱情。达里尔，这真的是你想要的吗？好好想想吧。我也对瓦尔感到困惑，因为瓦尔看起来对这段感情可有可无。我不知道他们俩是否都在用正确的方式处理
But then all that happens is you're gonna like move to Philly and have no love in your life. Daryl, is that what you want? Think about it. I'm also confused by Val too, because Val seems like she could either take them or leave them. I don't know that either of them are approaching
这段关系。我觉得瓦尔对这段关系的投入一直比达里尔少一点。我的意思是，达里尔比布兰登强一点，不过嘛。也许只是退了一步。比原地踏步稍微好一点。至少，你知道的，我不清楚，布兰登在其他人看来像个混蛋，
this relationship in the right way. I feel like Val has always been a little less invested in the relationship than Daryl. I mean, Daryl is a step up from Brandon, but you know. Maybe a side step. Slightly better than a lateral move. At least, you know, I don't know, Brandon seemed like a jerk to other people,
也许对瓦尔不是这样。帕姆本来要走到梅雷迪思的桌子前索取她的办公用品申请表，但梅雷迪思说，别唠叨了。难怪吉姆会抛弃你。然后她开始疯狂地挠头。帕姆心想，哦不，哦不。艾琳注意到了这一切。
maybe not to Val. Pam was gonna go up to Meredith's desk and she needs her supply request, but Meredith says, just stop nagging. Any wonder Jim left you. And then she starts scratching her head like really hard. And Pam's like, oh no, oh no. Erin clocks all of this.
是的，她开始检查梅雷迪思的头皮，你猜怎么着？虱子。艾琳甚至有点自吹自擂，她对虱子了解很多，因为她以前得过22次。没错。她是专家。每个人瞬间都开始针对梅雷迪思。安吉拉指责她没有签署淋浴保证书。德怀特则说，锁上门。我们要进入全面隔离状态。帕姆说，大家放松点。这只是虱子。我是说，也许吧。帕姆说，大家放松，这只是虱子。我是说，也许吧。
Yeah, she starts inspecting Meredith's scalp and guess what? Lice. Erin kind of brags, she knows a lot about lice because she had it 22 times. Yep. She's an expert. Everyone immediately turns on Meredith. Angela accuses her of not signing the pledge to shower. Dwight is like, lock the doors. We're going to be under full quarantine. Pam's like, relax guys. It's just lice. I mean, maybe. Pam's like, relax, guys, it's just lice. I mean, maybe.
嗯哼。德怀特说他以前得过一次虱子。那是开学第一天，在那之后的15年里他都被人取笑。没有人愿意和他玩。他们叫他怪胎、四眼田鸡、科幻书呆子，还有打女孩的人，这一切都因为他在七岁时得过虱子。哦，德怀特。我懂。
Mm-hmm. Dwight says he had lice once. It was the first day of school, and he was teased for 15 years after that. No one would play with him. They called him a freak, four-eyed, sci-fi nerd, and girl puncher, all because he had lice when he was seven. Oh, Dwight. I know.
但你猜怎么着？德怀特没有虱子。艾琳检查了他。他身上没有虱子。于是他开始向每个人喷洒消毒剂。我们收到了来自纽约州罗切斯特市杰西卡·N的粉丝提问，她想知道，他喷的是什么？
But guess what? Dwight does not have lice. Aaron inspects him. He is lice-free. And so he starts spraying everybody with a disinfectant. And we had a fan question from Jessica N. in Rochester, New York, who wanted to know, what is he spraying?
一定只是水雾吧？是的，杰西卡，那是依云矿泉水喷雾，就像个喷雾器一样。我们只是在罐子上换了个不同的标签。艾琳现在正在检查每个人。当她开始检查安吉拉的头皮时，安吉拉提醒梅雷迪思，这里是办公室，可不是她那些豆袋床狂欢派对。什么是豆袋床狂欢派对？
It has to be water vapor, right? Yes, Jessica, it is an Evian water spray, like a mister. And we just put a different label on the can. Erin is now inspecting everyone. As she starts going through Angela's scalp, Angela reminds Meredith that this is an office, not one of her beanbag orgies. What is a beanbag orgy?
难道只是一群人在一堆豆袋床上狂欢吗？就像在一堆豆袋上？哦。对吧？是的，我想是的。我想就是你在地上扔一堆豆袋，然后就开始狂欢？然后就开始了。我没去谷歌。
Is it just an orgy on a bunch of beanbags? Like on a pile of beanbags? Oh. Right? Yeah, I guess. I guess it's just you throw some beanbags on the floor and then there's an orgy? And you get to it. I didn't Google it.
我也没去谷歌。闭嘴。不，别去谷歌。别搜，好吗？把手机收起来。别搜。别搜。好吧。
I did not Google it either. Shut up. No, don't Google it. Don't do it, right? Put your phone away. Don't do it. Don't do it. Okay.
帕姆开始为梅雷迪思辩护。她说，你知道的，我们有点过早地责怪她了。奥斯卡可没那么确定。然后真相大白，安吉拉、斯坦利、帕姆和奥斯卡身上都有虱子。身上都有虱子。德怀特穿着全套生化防护服回来了。他说如果你一年租四次以上，买一套才是最划算的。我确实查了一下。它们其实没那么贵。
Pam starts to come to Meredith's defense. She's like, you know, we're kind of blaming her prematurely. Oscar's not so sure. And then it's revealed that Angela, Stanley, Pam, and Oscar all have lice. All have lice. Dwight is going to return in a full hazmat suit. He says if you rent it more than four times a year, it just makes sense to buy it. I did look it up. They're not that expensive.
买一套？你花100美元左右就能买到一个。你知道吗？这让我想起了我的躺椅，我已经租了好几次了。我一直劝你直接把那破玩意儿买下来。我的意思是，我已经买过三个躺椅了。直接买吧。
To buy? You can get one for like $100. You know what? This is reminding me of my recliner, which I've rented several times now. I keep telling you to just buy the damn thing. I mean, I've bought three recliners at this point. Just buy it.
我知道你说它不太符合你家的美式审美，诸如此类的。不仅勉强塞不下那个房间。我们不得不把床推到墙边才能腾出地方放它。你见过我们为乔什的下背痛买的那把巨大的牙医椅吗？每当我们坐下来看节目时，给自己留一分钟，因为这就是你会听到的声音。
I know you said it doesn't really fit the aesthetic of your house, etc., etc. Not only it doesn't fit in the room barely. We had to move the bed against the wall to fit it. Have you seen the ginormous dentist chair that we got Josh for his lower back? Whenever we go to watch a show, just give yourself a minute, because this is what you're gonna hear.
吱、吱、吱、吱、吱、吱、吱、吱。当他把双腿调整到合适的位置时，他有一个可以向前推或向两边拨的小开关。然后，天哪，如果他说，哦，我觉得我要去躺椅上了。然后在凌晨两点，李不得不听到，呢。哦，天哪，我要疯了。我要疯了。我想买一张可调节的床。事情是这样的。我摔断了肩膀。
Wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee. As he gets his legs in the right position, he has a little toggle that he can push forward or side to side. And then, God forbid, he's like, Oh, I think I'm gonna the recliner. And at 2 a.m. Lee has to hear, neee. Oh my gosh, I go crazy. I go crazy. I think I wanna get an adjustable bed. Here's what happened. I broke my shoulder.
我习惯了以这种特定方式仰睡，以至于现在我需要升降功能。你当时睡不着。我躺着根本睡不着。我妈，我们给我妈买了一张，我是说，她都八十多岁了，但你知道的，当机立断。你马上就要50岁了。一张可调节的床。
I got so used to sleeping on my back in this one way that now I need the lift. You couldn't sleep. I couldn't sleep laying down. My mom, we got my mom, I mean, she's in her eighties, but you know, there's no time like the present. You are turning 50. An adjustable bed.
这就是我目前的生活。我开始接受它了。我兴奋得无以复加。不管怎样，德怀特早该买下那套防化服的。他这么做是对的。真不错。我们是不是该聊聊那些没有虱子的人，也就是蓝色小分队，菲利斯、凯文和内莉？
This is what my life has become. I'm leaning into it. I couldn't be more excited. Anyway, Dwight should have just bought the Hezmat suit. He was right to do it. That's good. Should we talk about the folks that don't have lice, AKA the blue group, Phyllis, Kevin, and Nellie?
也许他们血型都一样。哦，也许是的。他们也都穿着蓝色衣服。而且达里尔没有虱子。仓库里的人很安全。德怀特对无虱子小分队说，滚开，下去，去仓库工作，于是他们开始收拾东西。
Maybe they're all the same blood type. Oh, maybe they are. They're also all wearing blue. And Daryl doesn't have lice. And the warehouse, they're safe. Dwight is going to tell the no-lice group, get out of here, go down, work in the warehouse, so they're going to gather their things.
当他们走到电梯口时，达里尔说，嘿伙计们，我有几条规矩。别碰打包机，而且在我跟瓦尔面前放尊重点，因为我们分手了。好吧，菲利斯、凯文和内莉，他们听到这个消息很难过。他们心想，哦天哪，太让人难过了。他们真的很同情达里尔。这将引发整整一条故事线。
And when they get to the elevator, Darryl says, hey guys, I have a few rules. Don't mess with the bailer and be cool in front of me and Val, because we broke up. Well, Phyllis and Kevin and Nellie, they take that hard. They're like, oh my gosh, that's so sad. They really feel for Darryl. This is gonna start a whole storyline.
他们对太他好了。我知道。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州希尔斯伯勒市艾米丽·B的粉丝提问，她说，为什么凯文这一集里亲了那么多人的脸颊？先是达里尔，后来又是瓦尔。那是剧本写好的还是即兴发挥的？
They're so nice to him. I know. We had a fan question from Emily B in Hillsboro, North Carolina, who said, what's up with Kevin kissing so many people on the cheek in this episode? First Daryl and later Val. Was that scripted or improvised?
好吧，艾米丽，我翻看了剧本，发现了一件非常有趣的事。哦，说来听听。所以这场戏在拍摄初稿中比最终播出的成片要短。我们什么时候说过这话？更短。从不。从不。
Well, Emily, I went to the script and I found out something very interesting. Oh, let's hear it. So this scene was shorter in the shooting draft than what ended up in the episode. When do we ever say that? Shorter. Never. Never.
是的。我发现的是这个。它在达里尔告诉他们分手消息后就结束了。后面所有关于他们试图安慰他、凯文把巧克力棒递给他、内莉说歌手布兰迪曾带她度过难关的内容。这些全都不在我们的拍摄剧本里。所有这些都是后来加进去的。
Yeah. Here's what I found. It ended after Daryl gave them the news about the breakup. That whole second part about them trying to comfort him and Kevin giving him his chocolate bar and Nellie saying that the singer Brandy got her through. None of that was in our shooting script. All of this was added later.
我们拍摄当天发了一页剧本重写页。所有这些额外的细节就是从那儿来的。上面根本没有关于凯文亲吻达里尔脸颊的内容。我想那纯粹是他们现场发挥的。不过，原本凯文手里拿的是一包薯片，他把薯片递给达里尔。不知怎么的，那变成了巧克力棒。
There was a script rewrite page handed out on the day that we shot this. And that is where all of this extra detail came out. There was nothing about Kevin giving Darryl a kiss. I guess that was just something they came up with. However, originally Kevin was holding a bag of potato chips and he offers Darryl the potato chips. Somehow that got changed to candy bar.
我在想布赖恩是不是即兴发挥亲了达里尔的脸颊。然后可能后来对瓦尔也这么做了。是的。因为这两处都不是剧本写好的。嗯哼。好吧，我觉得克雷格作为达里尔的反应真的很好笑。也许是因为太出乎意料了。是的。
I wonder if Brian improvised the kiss on Darryl's cheek. And then maybe later to Val. Yeah. Because neither of those were scripted. Mm-hmm. Well, I thought Craig's reaction as Darryl was really funny. Maybe because it was a surprise. Yeah.
帕姆现在要面对镜头说内心独白了。詹妮弗，你在这里演得太棒了，因为你一开始表现得非常叛逆。你说，你知道吗，也许虱子真是梅雷迪思带进来的，而且它们跟西西得的那种不一样。别妄下结论。谣言就是这么开始的。然后当帕姆终于妥协，说，好吧，我告诉她，我招了。我觉得这段独白太棒了。我太喜欢你的表演了。非常感谢。当我观看时，它让我想起了《盲婚试爱》第六季中劳拉质问杰瑞米的场景。我不看《盲婚试爱》。在他流连酒吧直到凌晨5点之后。哦天哪，这太具体了。看过那一季的人都会知道
Pam now has a talking head. And Jenna, you're so good in it because you start off so defiant. You're like, you know what, maybe Meredith did bring lice and they different from the ones that Cece got. And don't jump to conclusions. That's how worse gets started. And then when Pam just gives in and is like, fine, I'll tell her, I'll confess. I thought it was such a good talking head. I loved your performance. Thank you so much. When I watched it, it reminded me of Jeremy being confronted by Laura in Love is Blind season six. I don't watch Love is Blind. After he stayed out at the bar till 5 a.m. Oh my god, this is so specific. Anyone who watched that season will know
我在说什么。但当我看到杰瑞米对劳拉做出那个举动时，它也让我想起了迈克尔·斯科特，以及他在乔治·福尔曼烤架上烫伤脚时那种防备的姿态。这个叫杰瑞米的家伙，他根本就没回家。他坐在客厅里。大约早上6点。他戴着眼镜，太阳镜。然后他的未婚妻进来了。她说，我们要一整天都戴着墨镜吗？
what I'm talking about. But when I saw Jeremy do that moment with Laura, it also reminded me of Michael Scott and how defensive he is about burning his foot on the George Foreman Grill. This guy Jeremy, he just didn't come home. And he's sitting in the living room. It's like 6 a.m. He's got glasses on, sunglasses on. And his fiance comes in. She's like, are we leaving the glasses on all day?
然后他把眼镜摘了。她超级冷静。他说，你想聊聊这个吗？她说，我觉得我们应该聊聊。是的，你昨晚没回家。他说，你想让我说什么？我和朋友出去了。然后，好吧，莎拉·安出现了。我能怎么办？我必须和她谈谈。我们必须做个了断。她说，对啊，酒吧凌晨2点关门。你从两点到五点去哪儿了？
And he just takes them off. She's super calm. And he's like, what do you want to talk about it? She's like, I think we should. Yeah, you didn't come home last night. And he's like, what do you want me to say? I went out with my friends. And then, okay, Sarah and showed up. What am I supposed to do? I had to talk to her. We had to get closure. And she's like, yeah, the bar closes at 2 a.m. Where were you from two to five?
他说，我们在车里。我们在聊天，好吗？我把定位发给你了。但这感觉就超级有防备心，就像，老兄，这是你的问题，责任在你，哥们儿。确实在你，哥们儿。你未婚妻对你昨晚行踪的任何疑问
He's like, we were in a car. We were talking, okay? I sent you my location. But it's just like super defensive, like, dude, it's you, it's on you, buddy. It is on you, bud. Any question that your fiance has about your whereabouts
都完全合情合理。是的。他有没有说过，好吧，行吧？没有。哦，天哪。他只是保持那种态度，有点像，好吧，好吧，我再告诉你一遍。我们在车里。
last night are super valid. Yeah. Does he ever say, OK, fine? No. Oh my gosh. He just sort of remains sort of like, kind of like, oh, fine, I'll tell you again. We were in the car.
我们在聊天。这太像迈克尔·斯科特了，就像，我喜欢培根的香味，好吗？告我啊。然后她说，我喜欢培根的香味，好吗？告我啊。然后她说，莎拉·安是怎么回家的？他说，对，我开车送她回家的。每一层谎言都让人觉得，等等，情况越来越糟了。但就像，你为什么顶着一头睡乱的头发？废话，我累了。
We were talking. It's very Michael Scott, like, I like the smell of bacon, OK? Sue me. And then she's like, I like the smell of bacon, okay? Sue me. And then she's like, how did Sarah Ann get home? And he's like, yes, I drove her home. Every layer is like, wait, it's getting worse. But it's like, why do you have bed head? Duh, I was tired.
她说我可以躺在她的床上。怎么，你想让我疲劳驾驶回家吗？你想让我给你画张地图吗？太搞笑了。哦，天哪。非常抱歉，杰瑞米。我确信你是个好人，但你因为这场戏成了网上的笑料。好多人都重新演绎了这一幕。
She said I could lay on her bed. What, you want me to drive home tired? You want me to draw you a map? That was so funny. Oh my gosh. I'm so sorry, Jeremy. I'm sure you're a nice person and you became fodder for the internet with this scene. So many people have recreated it.
我完全不知道你在说什么。我知道。就像一无所知。我甚至不需要去查，因为我现在着迷了。我今天成了离题女王。我道歉。听着，我们在哪儿？我们在豪华轿车里。好吧，吉姆在狂饮我猜是含羞草鸡尾酒的东西。这是鲜榨橙汁吗？他问。他乐坏了。他问能不能拿点零食，
I don't know anything you're talking about. I know. Like nothing. I'm not going to have to look it up because I'm now fascinated. I'm tangent lady today. I apologize. Listen, where are we? We're in a limo. Okay, Jim is downing what I think are mimosas. Is this orange juice fresh squeezed? He asks. He's tickled. He asks if he can take some snacks.
然后司机把他放在路边，他说，等等，这是……我在哪儿？司机说，这是J博士的私人球场。你将在这里见到他。吉姆心想，你在开玩笑吧。是的。好吧，关于这场戏里的豪华轿车司机，我有一个有趣的故事。我听说过这个故事。
And the limo driver drops him off on the sidewalk, and he's like, wait, is this... Where am I? And he says, this is Dr. J's private court. You'll be meeting him here. Jemma's like, you've got to be kidding me. Yeah. Well, I have a fun story about the limo driver in this scene. I know this story.
你打完电话后我整个人震惊了，什么？我知道。这就是所谓的纯属巧合。所以今年早些时候，我在外地拍一个项目。我还不能透露细节，但我迫不及待想告诉你们。超级好玩。所以我当时在外地拍戏，制作公司安排了一辆车去机场接我。对。我上了车，司机人非常好，
You called me after and I was like, what? I know. This is talk about random coincidence. So earlier this year, I was filming a project out of town. I can't share about it yet, but I can't wait to tell you guys. It was super fun. So I'm filming out of town and the production company arranged for a car to pick me up from the airport. Yep. I get in the car and the driver was really nice
我们聊了起来，他说，天哪，你看起来好眼熟，我说，我知道，我也觉得你眼熟，然后我们沉默了一会儿，他接着说，等等，你是不是演过《办公室》？我说，对，我演过。我扮演了，你知道的，安吉拉，会计部的。他说，我也演过《办公室》？我说，什么？太疯狂了。是的。他说，好吧，那是第九季。我说，等等，我有个播客。我们刚开始讲第九季。他说，好吧，还记得吉姆坐加长林肯去见J博士的那场戏吗？我说，哦，天哪，原来那个人是你！他说，是的，他叫杰夫·哈奇。他是个极好的人。我说，杰夫，我能采访你上我的播客吗？
and we get to talking and he was like gosh you look familiar and I was like I know you look familiar too and we're just like huh and then we sort of write in silence and he's like wait were you on the office and I said yeah I was I played you know Angela in accounting and he said I was on the office? And I said, Yeah, I was. I played, you know, Angela in accounting. And he said, I was on the office too. And I said, What? So crazy. Yeah. He said, Okay, it's season nine. And I was like, Wait, I do a podcast. And we just started season nine. He goes, Okay, remember when Jim gets picked up in a limo to go meet Dr. J? And I was like, Oh, my God, that was you. And he said, yes, his name is Jeff Hatch. He is the loveliest person. And I was like, Jeff, can I interview you for my podcast?
我们正开在405号高速公路上。他说，没问题，我就坐在后座上。所以我有点往前倾。他正朝前开着。音质可能不是最好的，但他真的太可爱了。这真的是一个非常有趣的重聚时刻，一个迷你的办公室重聚。我希望你们听听这个。我太喜欢了。你好，办公室女士们的听众们。我现在正和杰夫·哈奇坐在一辆车里。嗨。
We're driving down the 405 freeway. He's like, sure, I'm in the backseat. So I'm kind of leaning forward. And he's kind of facing forward. The sound quality is probably not the best, but he was so lovely. And this was such a fun reconnection moment, a little mini office reunion. I want you to hear it. I love this. Hello, office ladies, listeners. I am in the car with Jeff Hatch. Hi.
他在哪一集里扮演了豪华轿车司机？就是那一集《虱子》，约翰·k·西恩斯基的角色在办公室爆发虱子那天不在，因为他去见J博士了。哦，对了，那个在俄勒冈州波特兰市的篮球运动员，我在屏幕上短暂出场，扮演了接他去J博士办公室的豪华轿车司机。你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？
He played the limo driver in which episode? Was the episode lice and John Krasinski's character was out of the office the day they had Lice because he was meeting Dr. J. Oh, yeah the basketball player in Portland, Oregon and I was briefly on screen as the limo driver that picked him up and took him to Dr. J's office. And how did you get your job on the office?
我持有B类商业驾照，我会开加长林肯，因为那是我当时的职业，直到今天也依然是我的职业。我的台词说得还算挺有说服力的，而且我碰巧有一张演员工会卡。这就是全部的要求。就是这样。你当时有三句台词？我有三句台词。其中一句被剪掉了。
I had a Class B commercial license and I could drive stretch limos because that was my job at the time and still is my job to this day. And I delivered the lines halfway convincingly and I happened to have a SAG card. So that was the whole requirement. There you go. And you had three lines? I had three lines. One of them got cut.
所以你们只能欣赏我对约翰·克拉辛斯基说的那两句台词。我们是在机场认识的。在机场做我豪华轿车司机的本职工作，而不是电视剧里的版本。太棒了。太棒了。非常感谢你来到办公室女士们的播客。我的荣幸。我太喜欢这个了。
So you get to enjoy me delivering two lines to John Krasinski. And we just met at the airport. At the airport doing my job as a limo driver. The actual limo driver job, not the not the television version. Awesome. Awesome. Thank you so much for being on Office Ladies. My pleasure. I love that so much.
这有多随机？我的意思是，太疯狂了。伙计们，我们当时其实并不在豪华轿车里，只是让你们知道一下。那只是一辆巨大的SUV而已。哦，对，对，对。但他真的很好，我要在动态里给他点个赞。杰夫，谢谢你跟我聊
How random is that? I mean, so crazy. And you guys, we weren't in a limo, just so you know. It was just one of those big SUVs. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. But he was so lovely, and I'm gonna give a shout out to him in stories. Jeff, thanks for talking to me
你在《办公室》里的经历。太酷了。我知道每当我们需要找一个真正开车的人时，你都得有那种特殊的……专业的司机。对，特殊的驾照，还得是个演员。
about your time on The Office. That is so cool. Well, I know that whenever we had to have someone who was actually driving a car, you had to have that special... A professional driver. Yeah, a special license and also be an actor.
所以我们会根据这些标准来挑选演员。他表现得很棒。我知道。我觉得太棒了。非常可信。非常可信，非常自然，而且人特别好。啊，好了，说到这儿，我们为什么不休息一下呢？我在刚才这整段里一直在慢慢吃蛋糕。
And so we would cast people with those criteria. And he did great. I know. I thought it was awesome. Very believable. Very believable, so natural, and just a lovely person. Aw, well, on that note, why don't we take a break? I've been slowly eating this cake all through this last segment.
我知道这一直让你分心，安吉拉，但你不能给我蛋糕，又让我忍着不吃。我是一个喜欢蛋糕的女士。我知道，但我刚才也一直在看你吃，看着你尽量不让自己在吃的时候发出声音。我知道。所以那种感觉，就像想象一个人咬了一口，但他们尽量不让嘴唇完全碰到叉子。
I know it's been distracting you, Angela, but you can't give me cake and then make me wait to eat it. I'm a lady who likes cake. I know, but I was also watching you eat it and watching you try not to make noise while you eat it. I know. So that, like, imagine someone taking a bite, but they're trying not to let their lips fully touch the fork.
所以就是，哦，轰。非常抱歉。我们休息一下，我要把这吃完。好的。我们马上回来，因为帕姆要进厨房去抓包梅雷迪思刮光头。好吧，我们到了。我们在厨房里。梅雷迪思要开始刮光头了。她还
So it's like, oh, boom. So sorry. Let's take a break and I'm just going to eat it. Okay. We'll be right back because Pam is going to go into the kitchen to find Meredith shaving her head. Yeah. Well, here we are. We're in the kitchen. Meredith is going to start to shave her head. She also
在给下面加热一些脱毛蜡。没错。以防那些小虫子迁移。对。帕姆进来了，她本来打算坦白的，但她没时间了，因为梅雷迪思已经把头顶正中央的头发全剃了。我的天，你能想象吗？不，我不能。哦，天哪。我们收到了来自内布拉斯加州谷地罗斯·K的粉丝提问，她说，我想知道关于梅雷迪思剃头那场戏的所有幕后故事。
is heating up some wax for down south. That's right. Just in case the critters migrated. Yeah. Pam enters and she's going to confess, but she doesn't have time because Meredith has shaved the center of her head already. I mean, could you imagine? No, I can't. Oh, my goodness. We had a fan question from Rosie K. from Valley, Nebraska, who said, I need to know all about the scene where Meredith is shaving her head.
很显然她并没有真的把头剃光，但看起来太逼真了。他们是怎么把这拍得这么逼真的？她戴着带局部假发的发套吗？我必须知道。好吧，凯特给我们发来了一段音频剪辑，分享了这一切，你们一定要听听。这一切是如何运作的，所有的场景是如何运作的，尤其是那个我专门剃头的场景，就是那种你能亲眼看到的场景。是的，那场戏光是戴上带有部分假发的光头套就花了大约三个半小时。所以我看起来像本杰明·富兰克林。
Obviously, she didn't really shave her head, but it looks so real. How did they go about making this look so real? Is she wearing a cap with a wig? I must know. Well, Kate sent us in an audio clip sharing all about this and you got to hear it. How that all worked, all the scenes work, especially the one where I'm specifically shaving my head, like where you actually see it. Yeah, it took like three and a half hours to get into the bald cap with a partial wig for that scene. So I look like Benjamin Franklin.
然后他们让我把头发握在手里，就像我的手实际上放在头顶上，抓着多余的头发，这样你就看不出来了。那是一个非常快的镜头。然后我右手拿剃刀，左手抓住头顶的头发。接着我只是顺势一捋，让头发掉下来。所以这就是一点电影魔术。当我问这看起来像什么时
And then they had me put hair in my hand, like I actually had my hand on top of my head, holding the extra hair so you couldn't tell. It was a pretty quick shot. And then I had the razor in my right hand, hair on top of my head with my left hand. And then I just rolled it over and just like let the hair drop. So a little movie magic. When I said what does it look
像是在烤蛋糕。天哪，我觉得我刚才说得比当时更有趣，对吧？不管怎样，这挺酷的。就像是一个很酷的小幻觉。我可以证实这就是我们当时的做法。不过我记得这并不容易。非常难，因为她有那么多动作要处理。你知道的，比如她一只手得抓着假发，另一只手拿着剃刀，还得设法让头发都掉下来，她必须完成整套幻觉动作，对吧？是的，演技、时机还有微波炉，我觉得她做得太棒了，因为看起来真的很像她的头发在倾泻而下
like? I'm baking a cake. God, I think I said it funnier, right just then than I did at the time. Anyway, so that was kind of cool. It's like a cool little illusion. And I can say that is how we did it. I remember it was not easy, though. It was very hard because she had so much business to do You know like she had to hold fake hair in one hand a razor in another hand kind of like make it all Fall out she had to do that whole illusion right? Yeah, well acting and the timing and the microwave I thought she did a great job right because it really looks like her hair is just cascading down
是的，而不是她在抓着然后放手。这就是他们在周一拍摄的第一天练习的内容。是的，为了确保看起来足够逼真。帕姆现在有一段内心独白，她说，听着，我要去告诉她，但现在显然不是时候。我给她买个假发，我们以后拿这个当笑话。
Yes, not that she's holding it and letting it go. And this is what they practice that Monday, the first day that we filmed. Yeah, to make sure that it would look realistic. Pam has a talking head now where she says, listen, I'm gonna tell her, but now is clearly not the time. I'll buy her a wig, we'll laugh about it later.
哦，帕姆。帕姆还是没有……拿这个当笑话。哦，帕姆。帕姆还是没有告诉她。帕姆，帕姆，帕姆。在会议室里，德怀特正在开关于虱子的会议。上面有一张巨大的、恶心的巨型虱子虫子的照片。艾琳告诉大家，他们需要用蛋黄酱来让虱子窒息。他们需要找一个搭档，把蛋黄酱抹在彼此头上。是的。
Oh, Pam. Pam still hasn about it later. Oh, Pam. Pam still hasn't told her. Pam, Pam, Pam. In the conference room, Dwight is running a meeting about lice. And there's a big gross picture of a giant lice bug. And Erin is going to tell everyone they need mayonnaise to suffocate the lice. They're going to need to pick a partner, and they're going to put mayonnaise on each other's head. Yes.
梅雷迪思来到了会议室。这就是她露出整个光头的时候。她说她是唯一一个有种让虱子见识谁才是老大的光头。是的。我们收到了来自比利时埃姆林·C的粉丝提问，她说，这一集里有我全剧最喜欢的安吉拉台词。真的吗，埃姆林？是的。梅雷迪思剃光头后，她对办公室的人说，
Meredith arrives to the meeting. This is when she reveals her full bald head. She says she's the only one with the balls to show the lice who's boss. Yes. We had a fan question from Emeline C. in Belgium who said, this episode has my favorite Angela line of the whole series. Really, Emeline? Yes. After Meredith shaves her head, she says to the office,
拍张照吧，这样能留得久一点。安吉拉回答说，我们可不想让它留得久一点。太可怕了。安吉拉说话时的语气和腔调让我笑得前仰后合。这句台词是剧本写好的吗？如果是的话，剧本上到底是怎么写的？这场戏还有没有关于糖果袋的备选台词？请把一切都告诉我。是剧本写好的。
take a picture, it'll last longer. And Angela replies, we don't want it to last longer. It's horrible. Everything about Angela's delivery makes me laugh so hard. Was this line scripted? And if so, what did the script say exactly? Were there any candy bag alts for this scene? Please tell me everything. It was scripted.
我完全照着剧本念的。我真的很喜欢安吉拉对梅雷迪思的所有反应。所以，埃姆林，谢谢你注意到这一点。接下来还有一句，我说的是，你高兴了吗，帕姆？她是个怪物。是的，我知道。我也超级喜欢那个。帕姆主动提出去买蛋黄酱。
I delivered it exactly as it was written. And I really loved all of Angela's reactions to Meredith. So, Imalign, thank you for noting that. There's one coming up where I'm like, are you happy, Pam? She's a monster. Yes, I know. I love that too. Pam is going to offer to go and get the mayonnaise.
是的。她说，我去买。我去买蛋黄酱。因为她感到内疚。她是挺内疚的。在仓库里，达里尔、凯文、菲利斯和内莉都围坐在一张桌子旁。他们在工作。
Yeah. She's like, I'll get it. I'll go get the mayo. Because she's feeling guilty. She is. In the warehouse, we've got Darryl, Kevin, Phyllis, and Nellie all sitting around a table. They're working.
瓦尔跟达里尔打招呼。那场面，简直了。哦天哪。看看那样。内莉说，就像看了一场车祸。太尴尬了。菲利斯问达里尔，什么能让你感觉好点？达里尔说，也许是巧克力蛋糕，就像我外婆以前做的那种。
And Val says hi to Daryl. And it's just like, oh my gosh. Look at that. Nellie is like, it's like a car crash. So awkward. Phyllis asks Daryl, what would make you feel better? And he was like, maybe chocolate cake, like my grandmother used to make.
然后他站起来。他说，我需要一会儿来清醒一下。凯文觉得他需要一些拥抱和巧克力蛋糕。我太喜欢菲利斯为自己的巧克力玛芬极力辩解的样子了。她说，这不是——这可不行。不，因为那不是蛋糕。
And he gets up. He says, I need a minute to clear my head. Kevin thinks he could use some hugs and chocolate cake. And I loved when Phyllis gets really defensive about her chocolate muffin. She's like, this is not- This wouldn't do it. No, it's because it's not cake.
不，那只是个玛芬蛋糕。把我逗笑了。好吧，现在我们要去吉姆的大会议了。他和J博士，他们在投篮？是的，空心入网，哈尔珀特。太棒了。帕姆给吉姆打电话
No, it's just a muffin. Made me laugh. All right, now we're headed over to Jim's big meeting. He and Dr. J, they are shooting baskets? Yeah, nothing but net, Halpert. Amazing. Pam is gonna call Jim. She's unloading a bunch of mayonnaise from the car
她正从车上往下搬一堆蛋黄酱，结果全掉在她的脚边，摔得粉碎。那些都是真正的蛋黄酱罐子。我真的很喜欢拍那些让我掉东西、显得笨手笨脚的戏份。好吧，知道了。我喜欢笨手笨脚的。妈妈侦探们，你才是那个笨手笨脚的。我才是笨手笨脚的。哦，等我们有了自己的剧，我就可以演各种笨手笨脚的桥段了。在《妈妈侦探》里你才是笨手笨脚的。女士，还记得我们写的那部电影里，我翻过那个栅栏吗？是的。你太兴奋于拍一些特技镜头了。我喜欢那个桥段。我不知道为什么。所以我希望你们喜欢我扔蛋黄酱的戏，因为我演得很开心。
and it's falling at her feet and exploding. Those were real mayonnaise jars. I really have a lot of fun doing scenes where I get to drop things and be like fumbly. Okay, good to know. I love cluts. Mom detectives, you're the cluts. I'm the cluts. Oh, when we have our own show, I get to do clutsy things. You're the cluts and mom detectives. Lady, remember our movie that we wrote had me falling over that fence. Yes. You're so excited to do some stunt moments. I love to do that bit. I don't know why. So I hope you liked my mayo dropping because I enjoyed doing it.
我觉得你演得棒极了。溅得完美无瑕。确实。在这通吉姆和帕姆的电话里，又一次，他们俩都没有真正分享正在发生的事情。帕姆没有告诉他整个办公室的人都快要把蛋黄酱抹在头上了。吉姆没有告诉他自己正在喝鲜榨冰沙，还和J博士一起投篮。
I thought you did a great job. It splattered perfectly. It did. Once again, in this Jim and Pam phone conversation, neither of them are really sharing what's happening. Pam is not telling him that the whole entire office is about to put mayonnaise on their heads. Jim isn't sharing that he's drinking a fresh made smoothie and shooting baskets with Dr. J.
甚至连J博士都要送他一双日本产的耐克鞋。我知道。你知道的，那个耐克鞋的笑话非常搞笑，因为我想，我在看这一集时突然想起了这个。我想，耐克鞋？J博士才不穿耐克呢！这是什么鬼？那是什么？
And even Dr. J is gonna give him a pair of Japanese Nikes. I know. You know, that Nike joke is very funny because I guess maybe, I remembered this when I was watching the episode. I was like, Nike's? Dr. J didn't wear Nike's? What is that? What was that?
那是为了当成一个额外的笑话吗？因为J博士穿的是匡威。他在20世纪70年代让匡威Pro Leather球鞋名声大噪，就像一件大事一样，运动员突然开始让鞋子或服装变得出名。我完全记得那个。
Was that meant to be like an extra joke? Because Dr. J wore Converse. He like made the Converse pro leather famous, like back in the 1970s. It was like a big thing where like, you know, athletes are suddenly now making shoes or clothing kind of famous. I totally remember that.
我当时还挺为自己骄傲的，因为我对体育了解很多，但我确实记得那点。是因为你看了一部电影，里面有这个情节吗？不，我没看那个篮球片。我没看。李看的。我没看那个。不，我只是记得那不是耐克，那是另一款鞋。我不知道。我不得不去查到底是哪款鞋，我承认，但我确实记得那不是耐克。不过还有一件事，安吉拉，这让我想到了关于运动员和服装之类的事情，就是最近的，哦天哪，我觉得有点不好意思，因为我今天有太多题外话了。我不知道我是不是只是因为
I was very proud of myself because I know a lot about sports, but I did remember that. Is it because you watched a movie and it was in the movie? No, I didn't watch that basketball thing. I didn't watch it. Lee watched it. I didn't watch that. No, I just remembered it wasn't Nike that was a different shoe. I don't know. I had to look up what shoe, I confess, but I do remember it wasn't Nike that was a different shoe. I don't know.
你为我庆祝了生日，所以我才这么喋喋不休。而且你今天吃了一大块好蛋糕。摄入了太多糖分。但是你有关注美国职棒大联盟那个透视裤子的事件吗？什么？
I had to look up what shoe, I confess. But I do remember it wasn't Nike. But then the other thing Angela, that this made me think of about like athletes and clothing and stuff is the current, oh my gosh, I feel self-conscious because I've had so many side stories today. I don't know if I'm just excited
透视裤子？我不知道你在说啥。哦天哪，女士。哦天哪。好吧。这是《盲婚试爱》里的桥段吗？不，这不是《盲婚试爱》。这是本赛季美国职棒大联盟发生的真实事件。好吧
because you celebrated my birthday and I'm being real chatty. And you've had a nice big piece today. I don't know if I'm just excited because you celebrated my birthday and I'm being real chatty. And you've had a nice big piece of cake. A lot of sugar. But are you following this major league baseball thing with the see-through pants? What?
所以让他们看裤子还是看透视裤子，等一下，听起来真的很糟糕。我知道，我知道，我可不想看一帮男人穿着透视裤跑步。让我看滑垒——我还没见过滑垒，但我见过拉伸。好吧，等一下。让我退回前面。好吧，道奇队
The see-through pants? I don't know what you're talking about. Oh my gosh, lady. Oh my gosh. Okay. Is this on Love is Blind? No, this is not Love is Blind. This is a real thing with Major League Baseball this season. Okay
今年，这个赛季。他们有透视裤，但他们还有别的东西。
So let their pants or see their pants or see through let me back up Seems really bad. I know I know I don't need to see a bunch of men running and see through pants. Let me sliding I haven't seen any sliding yet, but I've seen stretching Okay, let me back up. Let me back up. Okay, the Dodgers I haven't seen any sliding yet, but I've seen stretching. Okay, let me back up. Let me back up. Okay, the Dodgers this year, this season. They have see-through pants, but they have something else.
所以让他们露出裤子或看到他们的裤子或透视，让我退一步，这真的很糟糕。我知道，我知道，我不想看到一群男人穿着透视裤跑步。让我滑一下，我还没看到有人滑垒，但我看到拉伸了。好吧，让我退一步。让我退一步。好吧，道奇队今年，这个赛季。他们有透视裤，但他们还有别的东西。
They have the greatest baseball player of all time. I can see Cassie, she's fist pumping right now. Shohei Otani, he's from Japan. He is a hitter and a pitcher. So in his debut game with the Dodgers, he hit a home run, but he's also the best pitcher. And he signed a deal with the Dodgers for like $700 million.
他们拥有史上最伟大的棒球运动员。我能看到卡西，她现在正在挥拳。大谷翔平，他来自日本。他既是击球手又是投手。所以在道奇队的处子秀中，他打出了一支本垒打，但他同时也是最好的投手。而且他跟道奇队签了一笔大约7亿美元的合同。
It's the biggest money deal of any athlete in any sport of all time. And the minute they got them, they gave them see-through pants? They did, lady. So here's what I found out. What the hell? It's not related, but I saw this podcast.
这是任何运动项目中任何运动员史上金额最大的合同。而他们一签下他，就给他发了透视裤？没错，女士们。所以我发现了什么。搞什么鬼？这没有关系，但我看到了这个播客。
I listened to this podcast called Today Explained. You saw it just like my mom. Where can I watch your podcast? Where can I watch your podcast? Today Explained did a podcast on Shohei Otani, and I wanted to listen to it because I'm interested. This is a big deal. Yeah. My son is a Dodgers fan so we're into this and I was listening to this podcast and they were like there are two big things happening in Major League
我听了这个叫做《今日详解》的播客。你看到了，就像我妈妈一样。我在哪里可以看你的播客？我在哪里可以看你的播客？《今日详解》做了一期关于大谷翔平的播客，我想听听，因为我感兴趣。这可是件大事。是啊。我儿子是道奇队的球迷，所以我们很关注这个，然后我在听这个播客，他们说美国职业棒球大联盟
Baseball this season. One is Shohei Otani and the other are the see-through pants. Cassie do you know about the see-through pants? What? Bring in the picture. Cassie just said I have a picture. Okay, here's what happened. This season. Who missed the memo?
这个赛季有两件大事发生。一件是大谷翔平，另一件就是透视裤。卡西，你知道透视裤的事吗？什么？把照片拿出来。卡西刚刚说我有一张照片。好吧，事情是这样的。这个赛季。谁漏掉了备忘录？
How do you order see-through pants? Look at it. Look at what's happening. Putting on my glasses. Oh no. Yeah. Oh no. It's so unfortunate.
怎么会订购透视裤呢？你看它。看看发生了什么。戴上我的眼镜。哦不。是啊。哦不。太不幸了。
Oh no, they look like they have, they, Okay, so the legs part are real see-through. Yep. And then they tuck their shirt in. And when they tuck their shirt in, it looks like they're wearing ginormous granny panties. Here is what happened. Oh, fellas. They... They can't play in these. They have been playing in them.
哦不，它们看起来像是，它们，好吧，所以裤腿部分真的是透明的。没错。然后他们把衬衫塞进裤子里。当他们把衬衫塞进去时，看起来就像他们穿着巨大的老奶奶内裤。事情是这样的。哦，伙计们。他们……他们没法穿着这个比赛。他们一直穿着它们比赛呢。
No. Yes, they have. And they took all their photos and team pictures in them. No one, no one was like, um, guys, no one. I can't, I'm obsessed with this story now. So they introduced new uniforms this season, lighter, more breathable fabrics. That's good. Because you know, those baseball uniforms are so heavy.
不会吧。是的，他们确实穿了。而且他们所有的定妆照和全队合影都穿着它。没有人，没有人说，嗯，伙计们，没有一个人。我现在对这个故事着迷了。所以他们这个赛季推出了新队服，更轻、透气性更好的面料。这挺好的。因为你知道，那些棒球服太重了。
I've always wondered, why do do they wanna play in that? They're hot, they don't breathe. They don't breathe. They breathe now. They are sheer. They're like sheer. And the problem is any team with white pants, when they tuck in their top shirt,
我一直想知道，他们为什么想穿着那个比赛？很热，又不透气。不透气。现在透气了。它们太薄了。就像轻纱一样。问题是，任何穿白裤子的球队，当他们把上衣塞进去时，
it looks like they have like a diaper on. Granny panty diaper. But then when they like bend and stretch. No, no, no. It'santy diaper. But then when they like bend and stretch. No, no, no! Very a lot. Are there photos of them stretching? Yes. Oh no. Yes because it's awful. What are they gonna do about it? Are they doing anything about it? Can you see like jockstrap? And more lady! You see a lot. Jingle jingles and stuff. It's very a lot. And are they doing anything about it?
看起来就像他们包了个尿布。老奶奶内裤尿布。但当他们弯腰和拉伸时。不，不，不！非常多。有他们拉伸的照片吗？有的。哦不。是的，因为太糟糕了。他们打算怎么处理？他们有采取什么行动吗? 你能看到类似于护身裆的东西吗？还有更多呢，女士！你能看到很多。叮当响的东西之类的。非常之多。他们有采取什么行动吗？
This I can't find out. Are they changing the bottoms? I haven't heard anything, but I've heard jokes that they think more women are going to watch baseball now. I mean, I'm telling you, it's bonkers. This of all the things I thought we were going to talk about today for this slice episode, it was not that you can see all the bits of the baseball player. And they're all wearing them.
这个我查不到。他们要换裤子吗？我没听到任何消息，但我听到有人开玩笑说，他们觉得现在会有更多女性观看棒球比赛了。我是说，真的，这太疯狂了。在今天这期“切片”节目中，我想我们要讨论的所有事情里，绝对不包括你可以看光棒球运动员的所有部位。而且他们每个人都穿着。
And if you go online, there's all these, it's very funny that people have put saran wrap on their legs and they're like, I got a pair of the new pants. Like, you know, cause they are very sheer. What's gonna happen when someone slides? Are they durable, but sheer? We don't know. We don't know yet. They gotta be durable.
如果你上网，会发现所有这些，人们在腿上裹上保鲜膜然后说“我买到了一条新裤子”，这太搞笑了。就像，你知道的，因为它们非常透明。当有人滑垒时会发生什么？它们耐穿但又很薄吗？我们不知道。我们还不知道。它们必须得耐穿。
None of them wanna slide. None of the white pants teams, nobody wants to slide. It's gonna be, what's gonna happen? Oh, wait, Jordan has an update. Yeah, so this is from sportsillustrated.com and the MLB said in a statement, the uniform pants have the same material and thickness as the uniform pants used last season.
他们谁都不想滑垒。穿白裤子的那些球队里没有人想滑垒。这会变成，会发生什么呢？哦，等等，乔丹有最新消息。是的，这是来自sportsillustrated.com网站的消息，美国职棒大联盟在一份声明中表示，比赛队服的材质和厚度与上个赛季使用的比赛队服相同。
There were changes to the fabric of the jersey, not the pants. No, there's no way. The pants did not look like this last year That cannot be possible. This is a cover-up story mom detectives. We're on the see-through pants I guess we have to go to Dodger Stadium now. We do. Oh my gosh. I don't even know where we are I'm so sorry for that crazy tangent. Um, cause we were talking about Dr. J and his shoes. I'm tangent lady today.
球衣的面料有改动，但裤子没有。不，绝对不可能。去年的裤子看起来可不这样。这绝不可能。这是个掩盖事实的故事，妈妈侦探们。我们在追查透视裤呢。我想我们现在得去道奇体育场了。我们必须去。哦天哪。我甚至不知道我们在哪。我很抱歉刚才扯得太远了。嗯，因为我们刚才在谈论J博士和他的鞋子。我今天是个跑题女王。
Well, I'll take us back to the conference room. Mayonnaise is being distributed y'all. They're gonna split up into pairs. Yeah, and while Dwight is sort of talking to everyone about this, he cuts his own hazmat suit with the scissors. He freaks out, he runs out of the room. Yes. Fan question from Claudia S. in Sydney, Australia.
好吧，我把大家带回会议室。防辐射面霜，哦不，是蛋黄酱正在分发，各位。他们要分成两人一组。是的，正当德怀特在跟每个人谈论这事时，他用剪刀剪破了自己的生化防护服。他吓坏了，跑出了房间。是的。来自澳大利亚悉尼的克劳迪娅·S.的粉丝提问。
I never heard of killing lice with mayonnaise. Does that actually work? Well, fan question from Ava F. in Hadesburg, Mississippi says, yes, you can put mayo on your hair and it will suffocate the lice, but you need to leave it on for six to eight hours, not just four hours, and then seven to eight days later you have to do it again. You can also use olive oil.
我从来没听说过用蛋黄酱杀虱子。那真的管用吗？好吧，来自密西西比州海蒂斯堡的艾娃·F.的粉丝提问说，是的，你可以在头发上抹蛋黄酱，它会闷死虱子，但你需要让它停留六到八小时，而不仅仅是四个小时，然后在七到八天后你必须再做一次。你也可以用橄榄油。
I feel like this is all stuff my grandmother knew. Like we would get a bug bite and she'd be like, go get clear nail polish. I'm going to put a little. That works. Yes. It suffocates the little bug. Yeah. you're right. I forgot about that trick. Yeah. So I guess yes you can use mayo. I think I would just use like a nice shampoo though. Why are you whispering it? Are you just telling me? Are you whispering to everybody? I mean I guess everyone's gonna know but I would just go the, I don't think I would do mayo. You know what, sometimes you gotta work with what you got.
我觉得这些都是我奶奶知道的窍门。比如我们被虫子咬了，她就会说，去拿透明指甲油。我要涂一点。那管用。是的。它能闷死小虫子。是的。你说的对。我忘了那个诀窍了。所以我想是的，你可以用蛋黄酱。不过我想我只会用那种不错的洗发水。你为什么小声说？你是在单独告诉我吗？你是在对大家耳语吗？我的意思是，我想每个人都会知道，但我还是会去，我觉得我不会用蛋黄酱。你知道的，有时候你只能就地取材。
Well, that's true. If you got mayo and it's bad, use the mayo, I guess. If I was out in the woods, Yeah. I would just use mayo or olive oil. Here is who all got paired up together, Angela and Oscar, Aaron and Pete, Creed and Pam, Creed goes great, I got stuck with the weirdo.
嗯，那倒也是。如果你有蛋黄酱而且情况糟糕，那就用蛋黄酱吧，我猜。如果我在树林里，是的。我就会用蛋黄酱或橄榄油。以下是分组情况，安吉拉和奥斯卡，艾琳和皮特，克里德和帕姆，克里德说得太好了，我居然跟这个怪咖分到了一组。
Angela's gonna really slap that mayonnaise onto Oscar's head. Angela says, you don't want bugs because who knows where those bugs will end up. She's clearly still very angry at Oscar and is gonna really enjoy putting this mayonnaise on his head. We have a very cute Mayo application montage
安吉拉绝对会把那蛋黄酱狠狠地拍在奥斯卡的头上。安吉拉说，你肯定不想惹上虫子，因为谁知道那些虫子最后会爬到哪里去。她显然还在生奥斯卡的宏大气，而且会非常享受把这蛋黄酱抹在他头上。我们有一个非常可爱的蛋黄酱涂抹蒙太奇镜头
with Pete and Erin. Oh yeah. I went to the script and here is what it said, quote, "'Erin and Pete, both with their heads lathered in Mayo, ad-lib flirting, some suggested areas. Erin pushes all his hair into a mohawk. Erin arranges her hair in a Martha Washington. Have fun on set.
主角是皮特和艾琳。哦，是的。我查了剧本，上面是这么写的，引述如下：“艾琳和皮特，两人的头上都涂满了蛋黄酱，即兴调情，一些建议的场景。艾琳把他的所有头发都弄成莫西干头。艾琳把她的头发弄成玛莎·华盛顿的造型。祝你们拍摄愉快。
Budget 30 minutes. That was very funny. I've never seen that before in a script. I know, that's very cute. Well, I thought that scene was adorable. And I feel like when Ellie as Erin says, Eiffel Tower, that that was Jake's real laugh. Me too, me too.
预算30分钟。”这太搞笑了。我以前在剧本里从没见过这个。我知道，这太可爱了。嗯，我觉得那个场景太萌了。而且我觉得当艾莉饰演的艾琳说出“埃菲尔铁塔”时，那是杰克真实的笑声。我也是，我也是。
We got a fan mail flurry. People wanted to know if it was real mayonnaise, and if not, what was used, and did it smell, and how long did it take to wash out of our hair afterwards? My memory is that we used a thick hair conditioner, and that my hair was very, very, very conditioned and soft. Yes, that's exactly what it was. That's my memory as well.
我们收到了大量的粉丝信件。大家想知道那是真正的蛋黄酱吗？如果不是，用的是什么？它有味道吗？事后洗掉它花了多长时间？我的记忆是，我们用的是浓稠的护发素，而且我的头发被护理得非常、非常、非常柔顺。是的，完全就是这样。这也是我的记忆。
And it looked like mayonnaise, but actually smelled it was. That's my memory as well. And it looked like mayonnaise, but actually smelled pretty good. It was just a hair conditioner. I took my camera to set that day and I have some great pictures. I put them in our book, The Office BFFs, but the only photo I have of myself and Jake Lacey, just the two of us, from his whole time on the show, is the two of us with this mayonnaise on our heads. That's very funny. You know, we also had a fan question from Melissa S. in Statesville,
它看起来像蛋黄酱，但实际上闻起来。这也是我的记忆。它看起来像蛋黄酱，但实际上闻起来还挺香的。它只是一种护发素。那一天我带了相机去片场，拍了一些很棒的照片。我把它们放进了我们的书《办公室闺蜜》里，但我在节目拍摄期间和杰克·莱西合影的唯一一张照片，我们俩单独的合照，就是我们俩头上顶着这蛋黄酱的照片。太搞笑了。你知道，我们还收到了来自北卡罗来纳州
North Carolina, who said, how long on average did you have to keep that on your hair? I know sometimes one or two scenes can take multiple hours. Well, I remembered that we grouped these mayonnaise scenes together, and Steve Burgess confirmed that. He said we did a full day and a half day of mayo hair. Yeah. I also remember my head being cold, because the, it was like we had a hair mask on. Yeah.
斯泰茨维尔的梅丽莎·S.的粉丝提问，她说，平均而言，你们必须让那东西在头发上呆多久？我知道有时候一两个场景可能需要好几个小时。嗯，我记得我们把这些蛋黄酱的场景集中在一起拍了，史蒂夫·伯吉斯证实了这一点。他说我们拍了一整天和半天的蛋黄酱头发戏。是的。我还记得我的头觉得很冷，因为，那种感觉就像我们在头上敷了发膜。是的。
It was very, like, damp. And it sort of took the temperature of the room, and our set was really cold. Meredith applies mayo to Stanley and Pam does the mayo on Creed's scalp but then Creed doesn't want to do Pam's. So now Pam is left trying to do her own. I know. Well in this sort of really messy process of her putting mayo on her own hair, her phone rings and she can't answer it because she's got the mayonnaise all over her fingers. So with her elbow, she kind of hits the speaker phone button and it's her mom. And her mom announces to the whole bullpen that CC school
感觉非常湿冷。它有点吸收了房间里的温度，而我们的片场真的很冷。梅雷迪思给斯坦利抹蛋黄酱，帕姆给克里德的头皮抹蛋黄酱，但接着克里德不想帮帕姆抹。于是帕姆只能自己给自己弄。我知道。在这场她自己给自己抹蛋黄酱的非常混乱的过程中，她的电话响了，由于她的手指上全是蛋黄酱，她无法接听。于是她用手肘按下了免提键，电话是她妈妈打来的。她妈妈向整个办公区大声宣布，C.C.学校
says she still has lice and Pam might have it too. Pam rushes to hang up the phone, but that's it. Everyone has locked in on this. They can't believe it. And Jenna, I remember this moment at the table read when we read the script, the whole room erupted into laughter and I wanted to read how it was in the script. Yes. Pam finally manages to hang up, but it's too late. Everybody stares at her, completely aware
说她还有虱子，帕姆可能也传染上了。帕姆赶紧挂断电话，但已经晚了。所有人都被这个吸引了。他们简直不敢相信。詹娜，我记得在剧本围读时读到这幕时的情景，整个房间爆发出哄堂大笑，我想读一下剧本里是怎么写的。是的。帕姆终于设法挂断了电话，但为时已晚。每个人都盯着她，完全意识到
that Pam is actually patient zero, not Meredith. Angela says, oh my God. Off Pam's horror, Meredith says, shave her head. Shave her head! And Kate crushed it. It's so funny. I remember that. This was a really, really fun scene to shoot.
帕姆其实才是零号病人，而不是梅雷迪思。安吉拉说，天哪。在帕姆惊恐的表情下，梅雷迪思说，剃光她的头。剃光她的头！凯特演得绝了。太搞笑了。我记得那个。这真是一个非常非常有趣的拍摄场景。
I loved all the mayo falling off my fingers. Clutzy. Clutzy acting. I know. Again. Save it for mom detectives, lady. Well, everyone starts to yell at Pam. She's apologizing.
我喜欢所有从我手指上掉落的蛋黄酱。笨手笨脚的。笨手笨脚的演技。我知道。又来了。留着给妈妈侦探吧，女士们。好吧，每个人都开始对帕姆大喊大叫。她在道歉。
She said it's been so hectic with Jim being gone. And she really does apologize to Meredith. And that's what Angela's like, lot of good that does now, she's a monster. Yes. Then I just loved this next Meredith talking head. I loved it. Kate was so phenomenal in it, I thought we should hear it.
她说吉姆不在身边，事情实在是太多了。她真的向梅雷迪思道歉了。然后安吉拉就说，现在道歉有什么用，她就是个怪物。是的。然后我太喜欢接下来梅雷迪思的独白了。我太喜欢了。凯特在里面表现得太出色了，我觉得我们应该听听。
Who's the one that didn't bring Lys into the office? Meredith. Sure, I gave everybody pink eye once, and my ex keyed a few of their cars. And yeah, I BM'd in the shredder on New Year's, but I didn't bring the lice in. That was all Pam. I love it so much.
是谁把虱子带进办公室的？梅雷迪思。没错，我确实给每个人都传染过红眼病，我的前任还砸过他们好几辆车。对啦，我还在新年那天在碎纸机里大便了，但我可没把虱子带进来。那全怪帕姆。我太喜欢这段了。
Perfection. And so good. We learned so much information. Yes. Apparently, Meredith did give everyone pink eye once. And everybody's cars got keyed. And she took a poop in the shredder. Down in the warehouse, Val enters her office to find Phyllis, Kevin, and Nellie. They say, look, we heard you broke up with Darryl, and they really want her to take him back.
完美。太棒了。我们了解到了如此多的信息。是的。显然，梅雷迪思确实曾经让每个人都得了红眼病。而且每个人的车都被砸了钥匙孔。她还在碎纸机里拉了屎。在楼下的仓库里，瓦尔走进她的办公室，发现菲尔斯、凯文和内莉都在里面。他们说，听着，我们听说你跟达里尔分手了，他们真的很希望她能跟他复合。
Yeah. And Val's like, you know what? I'm gonna need you to leave my office. Is that all? And Nellie's like, no, that's not all. And then she has this huge speech. Yeah, we got a fan question about it from Nikita C. in Sydney, Australia, who said, can we talk about Catherine Tate's strange
对啊。然后瓦尔说，你知道吗？我需要你们离开我的办公室。就这些吗？内莉说，不，不止这些。然后她发表了一大段慷慨激昂的演讲。对，我们收到了澳大利亚悉尼的尼基塔·C.关于这部分的粉丝提问，她说，我们能聊聊凯瑟琳·泰特在说服瓦尔跟达里尔复合时那段奇怪
but incredible performance in convincing Val to get back with Daryl? I agree with you, Nikita, we can talk about it. I noticed though, I went to the script because I was curious that the script is different from what ended up in the episode. Only by two lines. Really? Only by two lines.
但不可思议的表演吗？我同意你的看法，尼基塔，我们可以聊聊。不过我注意到，我去翻了剧本，因为我很好奇剧本和最终播出的剧集有什么不同。只差了两台词。真的吗？只差了两句台词。
Angela, I was hoping that you would tell me what was up. Okay. So there were no candy bag alts for this. Okay. And Catherine really nailed it. She delivered it exactly as it was written, except for one part. And I don't know if Catherine just forgotten the moment and left out this couplet of dialogue
安吉拉，我本希望你能告诉我怎么回事。好吧。所以这部分没有备选的糖果袋台词。好吧。凯瑟琳真的演得很棒。她完全按照剧本台词念的，除了其中一部分。我不知道凯瑟琳是不是当时忘词了，漏掉了这几句对白
or if they decided on the day not to include it. But as she does her whole speech, she would have also talked about her countless plastic surgeries in which she had a merry-go-round of elective self-abuse. Oh my goodness. So I don't know if they decided that that was one too many. But I thought Catherine was so great in this moment. And I'm just giving shout outs to all of the Kates and Catherine's on our show, because I think we need to hear it.
还是他们当天决定不把它拍进去。但在她发表完整演讲时，她本来还应该谈到她无数次的整形手术，经历了一场又一场的自虐旋转木马。哦天哪。所以我不知道他们是不是觉得那个有点太多了。但我认为凯瑟琳在这个时刻表现得太棒了。我要向我们节目中所有的凯特和凯瑟琳致敬，因为我觉得我们需要听听这个。
Thank you. Is that all? No, no that is not all. Let me tell you what real life is like. The men dry up and the nights get lonely. The only calls on your machine are from collection agencies about that pair of motorcycle boots you've never even worn. You stalk your old high school boyfriend online, go to his daughter's soccer games and make a scene. You buy a diamond ring for yourself, wear it on your right hand and tell yourself you're all you need. One day you're alone, tired, at your feet a dying bird. Where did it come from? Why did you kill it? Is it because in some strange way it is you. Well, if you can believe it, that speech does not sway Val. Something else does.
谢谢。就这些吗？不，不，不只是这些。让我告诉你真实的生活是什么样的。男人们渐渐消失，夜晚变得孤寂。你电话答录机里仅有的留言来自催收公司，追问你那双甚至从未穿过的摩托车靴。你在网上搜寻你高中时期的前男友，去他女儿的足球比赛现场闹事。你给自己买了一枚钻戒，戴在右手，告诉自己有自己就够了。有一天你孤身一人，疲惫不堪，脚边躺着一只垂死的鸟。它从哪儿来的？你为什么要杀死它？是因为某种奇怪的原因，它其实就是你自己吗？好吧，如果你能相信的话，那段演讲并没有动摇瓦尔。别的东西做到了。
Shocker. Yes, it is actually because Kevin asks her out. Yeah. And then Val has a talking head that's just wonderful. Amina is so good in this moment. I think we should hear it. Okay. Yeah, Kevin asked me out.
真让人震惊。是的，实际上是因为凯文约她出去。对。然后瓦尔有一段非常精彩的独白。阿米娜在这个片段里演得太好了。我觉得我们应该听听。好吧。对，凯文约我出去。
I was kind of feeling good about reentering the dating pool, and then Kevin asked me out. Thought I might trade up to a new level of men. Then Kevin asked me out. Ah, it's so good. Every time she's like, and then Kevin asked me out. Yeah. Ladies are crushing it in this episode. Well, back in the bullpen, Dwight has been hiding in Andy's office, but he's using his
我对重新回到约会市场感觉还挺好，然后凯文约我出去。本以为我能升级到新层次的男人。然后凯文约我出去。啊，太棒了。每次她说“然后凯文约我出去”的时候。是的。女士们在这集中表现得太惊艳了。好吧，回到办公区，德怀特一直躲在安迪的办公室里，但他正用他的
megaphone to shout at everyone. And he says, you have 60 seconds to evacuate because I'm going to detonate this bug bomb fogger thing to disinfect the office, but then he accidentally drops it. He fumbles it. He has a klutz moment and it explodes. I think Dwight might be the clumsiest person at Dunder Mifflin.
扩音器向所有人大喊。他说，你们有60秒的时间撤离，因为我要引爆这个杀虫烟雾弹来给办公室消毒，但接着他不小心把它掉了。他手忙脚乱。他犯了个笨拙的失误，它爆炸了。我觉得德怀特可能是邓德米夫林最笨手笨脚的人了。
It's kind of true. He's already stabbed himself with the scissors. Yeah. Now he's dropped the bug bomb. But yeah, as you watch the show again, I think Dwight is the clumsiest. He might be. We had a fan question from Lindsay P. in Pottstown, Pennsylvania, who said, I laugh hysterically every time I see Dwight drop the lice bomb in Andy's office and then in his car at the
这倒有几分真的。他之前已经用剪刀把自己扎伤了。对。现在他又把杀虫弹给弄掉了。不过是的，当你再看这部剧时，我觉得德怀特就是最笨手笨脚的。他可能真的是。我们收到来自宾夕法尼亚州波茨敦的林赛·P.的粉丝提问，她说，每次看到德怀特把虱子炸弹掉在安迪办公室里，然后在剧集结尾掉在车里时，我都笑得前仰后合。请给我们讲讲这一切是如何拍摄制作的吧。来自佛蒙特州伯灵顿的玛吉·F.说，德怀特扔下杀虫剂时那团杀虫烟雾太搞笑了，请为我们剖析一下幕后的制作逻辑吧。嗯，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，这大部分都是在后期制作中完成的。哦，真的吗？因为时机太完美了。太完美了。
end of the episode. Please tell us everything about how this was done. And Maggie F. from Burlington, Vermont said, the cloud of insecticide smoke when Dwight drops it is so funny, please walk us through the logistics. Well, Steve Burgess said most of this was done in post-production. Oh, really? Because the timing is so perfect. It's so perfect.
而且是瞬间发生的。对。我们当时就在现场，安吉拉，但我完全不记得我们是怎么拍的了。所以谢天谢地，我们有史蒂夫·伯吉斯作为智囊。他说他们当时的做法是让雷恩（Rainn）定格不动，然后他们冲过去把烟雾和一点粉末残留物弄到他身上。接着他解冻并继续表演。但史蒂夫说，那个巨大的爆破和烟雾云
And it's instant. Yes. We were there, Angela, but I did not remember how we did this. So thank goodness we have Steve Burgess as a resource. He said that what they would do is have rain freeze, and then they would jump in and they would put smoke and then a little powder residue on him. And then he would unfreeze and continue the scene. But Steve said the big pop and the cloud of smoke
是后来在后期制作中加上去的。太棒了。真的做得很好。安吉拉现在在洗奥斯卡的头发。女士，当你用那个什么东西敲他的头时，那是音效吗？不是。女士！
was added later in post. So good. Really well done. Angela's now washing Oscar's hair. Lady, when you hit him in the head with the what is that, was that a sound effect? No. Lady!
他们告诉我要用玻璃壶敲他的头。天哪！他们可能把声音稍微调大了一点。但我知道那不是个假壶。不，那是个真的玻璃壶，但他们说你只需轻轻敲一下他的头。我说，好吧，奥斯卡，他说，直接敲吧。我说，好吧。所以我敲了他的头。
They told me to clunk him in the head with the glass pot. My gosh! They might've pumped up the sound a little bit. But I know that wasn't a fakey pot. No, it was a real glass pot, but they said you kind of bonk him in the head. And I was like, Oscar, and he goes, just do it. I was like, okay. So I bonked him in the head.
然后你把水倒在他满脸都是。我知道。他们也让我这么做的。那是剧本里写好的。听着，伙计们，上面写着，现在她把水倒进他的鼻子和脸上。你们当时在笑吗？你们是怎么撑过去的？谢天谢地那是奥斯卡。
And then you pour water all over his face. I know. They told me to do that too. That was scripted. Listen, you guys, it says, now she pours water up his nose and in his face. Were you guys laughing? How did you get through that? Thank God it was Oscar.
如果你对我这么做，我们早就笑场了，而且永远也拍不完了。我当时极力忍住不笑，因为当我用咖啡壶敲他时，他的反应太真实了。哦，不。但当我重温这些场景时，我记忆最深刻的一点之一，我在后面看艾琳和皮特洗头的那场戏时也有这种感觉，那就是那个水槽不是真的。哦，对哦。是吧？对。所以当你打开水龙头时，他们只是用了一个带水管的水桶，像一个水泵一样。对。
If you were doing that to me, we would have been laughing and we would have never finished. I was trying not to laugh because when I did bonk him with the coffee pot, his reaction was so honest. Oh, no. But when I was rewatching these scenes, one of the things I remembered so vividly, and I thought it when I watched Erin and Pete's scene as well that's coming up where she washes his hair, is that sink was not real. Oh, that's right. Right? Yeah. And so when you turned water, they just had sort of like a bucket with water with like a hose and it was like a pump like a pump. Yeah.
所以水压就像是在滴水。就像是，是的。所以我只记得当时很难让画面看起来有足够的水，而且你绝对不可能在那样的水槽里给别人洗头。不，确实如此。而且排水管，水直接流出来掉进了一个水桶里。是的，它从一个水桶流出，流进另一个水桶。确实如此。好吧，说到皮特要脱掉衬衫的那场戏。我知道，而且他肌肉线条好明显。哇哦。
So the pressure was like a dribble. It was like, yes. So I just remember that it was hard to make it look like there was enough water and there's no way you could wash someone's hair in that sink. No, that's right. And the drain, it just came out and fell into a bucket. Yes, it like went out one bucket, it like goes into another. That's true. Well, speaking of the scene where Pete is gonna take off his shirt. I know and he's all muscley. Hello.
我知道。这到底是怎么回事？他的头上还留着猫王风格的蛋黄酱发型。艾琳努力不去看他的二头肌，然后开始帮他洗头。这真是一个非常亲密的场景。我喜欢别人帮我洗头。我知道，感觉太棒了，对吧？
I know. What is going on? And he's got still his little Elvis Mayo hair. And Aaron's like trying not to look at his biceps and then starts washing his hair. This is a very intimate scene. I love getting my hair washed. I know, it feels so good, doesn't it?
是的，所以我们现在能体会到皮特的感受了。好吧，任何被别人洗过头的人都懂。我知道，我的意思是，任何人。我想，听着，当你去染头发时，他们会帮你洗头。那感觉太美妙了。太棒了。除非你遇到那种把指甲抠进你头皮太用力的人，当你去染头发时，他们会帮你洗头。那感觉太美妙了。太棒了。除非你遇到那种把指甲
Yeah, so we know what Pete is feeling right now. Well, anyone that's had their hair washed. I know, that's what I mean. Anyone. I guess, listen, when you get your hair colored, they wash your hair out for you. That's wonderful. It's so great. Unless you get the one person that digs their nails in your scalp too hard, and you get your hair colored, they wash your hair out for you. That's wonderful. It's so great. Unless you get the one person that digs their nails
抠进你头皮太用力的人，然后你会说，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿。是的。确实会这样。有时候那个人赶时间。说到头上的指甲，换个话题，我们节目的发型师黛比，她有那种很漂亮的指甲。
in your scalp too hard, and you're like, hey, hey, hey, hey. Yeah. That happens. Sometimes the person's in a rush. Speaking of nails on your head, but going another direction, Debbie on our show, our hairdresser, Debbie, she had those wonderful nails.
哦对，她的指甲很长。当她帮你整理发型时，是的。感觉就像是最棒的体验，我告诉她她应该开一家名为“黛比的贴心发型屋”的工作室。你只需要，比如在一天中间，你的头发开始变乱时，你去黛比的发型屋，她就会帮你打理一下发型
Oh yeah, her nails were long. And when she would touch up your hair, Yes. it was like the greatest, I told her she needed to open up a studio called Debbie's Touch-Ups. And all you would do, like middle of your day, your hair is getting crazy, you go in to Debbie's Touch-Ups and she'll just touch up your hair
然后她会用手指在你的头发里抓一抓，接着喷点防毛躁定型喷雾，然后你就可以继续一天的生活了。难道你不会为这个付费吗？如果是黛比来做的话。那只能是黛比的贴心发型屋。听我说，我今天完全没办法按计划录节目了。你确实没有。我简直没办法。那个，我是说。你真的没有。你知道吗？我只能说是因为那块蛋糕。你吃了很大一块蛋糕。我吃了。它让你整个人变得，像……
and she'll just put her nails in your hair and then like kind of spray the flyaways and then you go on with your day. Wouldn't you pay for that? If Debbie was doing it. It's only Debbie's touch-ups. Yes. Debbie's touch-ups. Listen to me, I cannot stay on course today. You can't. I literally can't. That, I mean. You can't. You know what? I'm just gonna say it was the cake. You had a big piece of cake. I did. It got you all, like...
我今晚特别健谈。……充满糖分。好吧，凯文当然开始把他能找到的所有气泡膜都塞进打包机里，尽管达里尔说过，千万别碰打包机。结果它要坏了。是的。凯文。然后瓦尔走向达里尔，你猜怎么着？她打算再给他一次机会。
I'm chatty tonight. ...sugared up. Well, Kevin, of course, is now putting all the bubble wrap he can find into the baler, even though Daryl said, do not mess with the baler. And it's gonna break. Yeah. Kevin. And then Val is gonna approach Daryl, and guess what? She's gonna give him another shot.
是的，她吻了他。她说，你知道吗？我坚信我们会有结果的。然后达里尔就说，我又和瓦尔复合了。耶。达里尔。达里尔。你太幸运了。达里尔。达里尔。她是个好姑娘。她是个好姑娘。拜托。接下来是德怀特走向他的车，并引爆了另一枚虱子弹。他又给弄掉了。又一次。皮特正要离开办公室，他在想艾琳是不是已经回家了。
Yeah, she kisses him. She's like, you know what? I believe in us. And then Darryl's like, I'm back with Val. Yay. Darryl. Darryl. You're so lucky. Darryl. Darryl. She's a catch. She's a catch. Come on. This is when Dwight is going to go to his car and set off another lice ball. He drops it again. Again. Pete is leaving the office, and he's wondering if Erin's already gone home for the day.
那个亲密的洗头时刻让艾琳躲到了走廊里。是的。这对她来说太亲密了，勾起了太多情绪。是的。吉姆和J博士还在打篮球，帕姆打电话过去但他没听到。她留了一条语音，听起来有点丧气。她只是说希望他这一天过得好点，梅雷迪思目睹了这一切，她
That intimate hair wash moment has caused Erin to hide in the hallway. Yeah. It was too much for her, brought up too many feels. Yeah. Jim and Dr. J are still playing basketball, and Pam calls and he doesn't hear it. She leaves a message, it's kind of a sad sack message. She just says she hopes his day got better, and Meredith watches all of this, and she
对帕姆的态度开始软化了。但其实在这之前还有一个场景，那才是真正让梅雷迪思对帕姆改观的开始。哦！帕姆从女洗手间出来，正用纸巾擦头发，安吉拉对她超级刻薄，而梅雷迪思无意中听到了。我想放给你们听听。现在看看这是谁！伤寒玛丽！
is softening towards Pam. But there was even another moment that would have come right before this that really started to turn Meredith around. Oh! Pam is coming out of the women's room, drying her hair with a paper towel, and Angela is super mean to her and Meredith overhears it. I want to play it for you. Now look who it is! Typhoid Mary!
安吉拉！别这样，帕姆。你把虱子带进了办公室。谁知道你身上还藏着什么？真恶心。太刻薄了。天哪。而梅雷迪思把这一切都听在耳里。然后帕姆试图给吉姆打电话。
Angela! Don't, Pam. You brought Lice into the office. Who's to say what else you have? Disgusting. So mean. Geez. And Meredith overhears all of this. And then Pam tries to call Jim.
梅雷迪思听到了那通电话。然后她说，你知道吗？我们去喝一杯吧。帕姆答应了。是的。我们收到了大量关于我在这集里的卷发的粉丝来信。当我打那通电话时，人们注意到了并说，
And Meredith hears that phone conversation. And she's like, you know what? Let's go grab a beer. And Pam says yes. Yeah. We got a fan mail flurry about my curly hair in this episode. When I'm doing that phone call, people noticed it and said,
你的头发超级卷，那是你真正的头发吗？你是把它做成这样的吗？如果那是你真的头发，你应该多留这样的发型，因为它看起来超级可爱。来自威斯康星州的格雷塔·V.说，我想插一句，詹娜，我喜欢你的自然卷。作为一个自然卷女孩，我喜欢在电视上看到自然卷。好吧，各位，谢谢你们。
your hair is super curly, is that your real hair? Did you style it like that? If it is your real hair, you should wear it like that more often because it looks super cute. And Greta V from Wisconsin said, I wanna pop in and say, Jenna, I love your natural curls. As a natural curly girl, I love seeing natural curls on TV. Well, everyone, thank you.
是的，当我的头发自然风干并稍微抓一下时，就是长那个样子。金·费里和我讨论过这个问题。这也是帕姆在早期剧季中做发型的方式。我们会把它抓出卷度，然后做成半扎半放的造型。但我也和格雷塔你一样，很喜欢在电视上看到我真实的自然头发。它的问题在于：
Yes, that is what my hair looks like when it air dries naturally and you scrunch it a little bit. And Kim Ferry and I discussed this. And this is also how Pam used to do her hair in early seasons. We would scrunch it and then do the half up, half down. But I also, like you, Greta, loved seeing my natural hair on TV. The problem with it is this.
它第二天无法保持原样。比如睡过一觉之后的第二天，它看起来就像是纠缠在一起，一团糟。所以如果我想要自然卷的造型，我实际上必须更频繁地洗头。但如果我把它稍微拉直再弄出卷度，那它就能保持几天。这就是为什么我不经常顶着自然发型的原因，第一，它必须自然风干，那要花好久时间。第二，它只能维持一天。接下来就会打结。是的。
It doesn't hold for a second day. Like the second day after I sleep on it like that, it looks like it's just tangled, like a tangled mess. So I actually have to wash my hair more often if I want to do the natural look. But if I kind of straighten it and add curl to it, then it can hold for a few days. So that's why I don't wear it natural more often because number one, it has to air dry, which takes forever. And then number two, it's a one day thing. And then it's tangled. Yeah.
所以。嗯，我超喜欢你自然的卷发。每当你给我发照片时，如果你在任何有海洋气息的地方，我都超喜欢。哦是的。因为你的头发。如果我靠近任何潮湿或有水的地方，我都不会把它拉直。你的头发会焕发出全新生机。
So. Well, I love your hair naturally curly. I love it whenever you send me a picture, if you are anywhere where there's like an ocean air. Oh yeah. Because your hair. I don't straighten it if I'm near any humidity or water. Your hair takes on a whole new life.
就像我迫切想看看你在夏天路易斯安那州的头发。天哪，那就像夏天的圣路易斯。我非得看看不可。关于这集我喜欢的另一件事是，我们确实看到了每个人湿漉漉的头发。看到大家那样真的很让人开心。确实挺有意思的。我同意。好吧，女士们现在要去Bog酒吧喝一杯。我太喜欢那个建立镜头了。你们这些来自斯克兰顿的人都知道Bog是一家真实的酒吧，我们都去过那里。是的，那是斯克兰顿的一家真实酒吧，安吉拉，你们2007年去斯克兰顿参加办公室大会时去过那里。不过我当时没去。
Like I need to see your hair in Louisiana in the summer. My gosh, that's like St. Louis in the summer. I need to see it. One of the other things I loved about this episode was we did get to see everyone with wet hair. And it was just such a fun thing to see everybody like that. It kind of was. I agree. Well, the ladies are now going to share a picture at the bog. I love that establishing shot. Those of you who are from Scranton know that the bog is a real bar and we've all been there. Yeah, it's a real bar in Scranton and Angela you guys went there when you were in Scranton for the 2007 office convention. I wasn't there though.
好吧，我的经历要更早。什么？是的，2007年5月，布莱恩和我自己去了斯克兰顿。那是在——在大会之前吗？对，大会是在10月份。我和布莱恩在5月份自己去了。我当时甚至从纽约出发。
Well I go further back. What? Yes, in May of 2007 Brian and I went to Scranton on our own. It was right after- Before the convention? Yeah, the convention was in October. And Brian and I went in May on our own. I actually left New York.
我很抱歉我服务过的每个人，因为我知道我的毛孔当时很不听话，但真的太好玩了。当时有一支当地乐队在现场演出，那真是一个美妙的夜晚。布莱恩和我至今仍在谈论那是多么特别的经历。我要向当时的斯克兰顿市长克里斯·多尔蒂致敬。他太棒了，整个小镇都让我们感到宾至如归。太酷了。
I'm sorry to everyone I served because I know my pores were real sloppy, but it was so much fun. There was a local band playing and it was just such a wonderful night. And Brian and I still talk about how special it was. I want to give a shout out to the Scranton mayor at the time, Chris Doherty. He was awesome, and the whole town made us feel so welcome. That is so cool.
好吧，遗憾的是，我们并没有去真正的Bog酒吧拍摄。我们在洛杉矶艺术区第七街的托尼沙龙进行了拍摄，那里靠近市中心。它现在还在。你仍然可以去。但我们的制片人给Bog的联合老板打了个电话。他叫布莱恩·克雷格。他们告诉他格雷格希望获得在节目中展现Bog酒吧的许可，
Well, unfortunately, we didn't get to go to the real bog to shoot. We shot at Tony's Saloon on 7th Street in the Los Angeles Arts District, which is near downtown. It's still there. You can still go. But our producers called the co-owner of the bog. His name is Brian Craig. And they told him that Greg would like permission to feature the bog on the show,
请他拍摄一些素材，他照做了，用他的iPhone拍的。我们尽量让它看起来一致。我相信我们在那个外景镜头里就用了那些素材。没错。那是真实的外景。说到倒酒，安吉拉，新罕布什尔州纳舒厄的艾米莉·P.的粉丝提问是这样的。我希望有一波关于
asked him to film some footage, which he did, on his iPhone. We tried to make it match. And I believe we used that footage for that exterior shot. Yes. That's a real exterior. And speaking of pouring drinks, Angela, fan question from Emily P. in Nashua, New Hampshire said this. I hope there is a fan mail flurry about the way
帕姆倒啤酒方式的粉丝信件，因为这让我太抓狂了。如果她那样给我倒酒，我会要求她给我买一杯没有变成“泡沫海洋”的新啤酒。你注意到这个了吗？我注意到了。你能读一下我用蓝色打印出来的东西吗？大声读出来。大声读出我写在文档里的内容。你写的是，帕姆根本不会倒啤酒。伙计们，我不喝啤酒。这很明显吗？是的。
Pam pours beer beer because it makes me so mad. If she did that to me, I would ask her to buy me a new beer that isn't poured into foam land. Did you notice this? I noticed it. Can you read what I printed in blue? Read out loud. Read out loud what I wrote in my document. You wrote, Pam does not know how to pour beer. You guys, I don't drink beer. Is it obvious? Yes.
没人想要那么多泡沫。你必须倾斜杯子，倾斜酒壶。我是说，我不知道。对，你确实不知道。我们当时喝的是菲尔的特制无酒精啤酒。它起泡沫的方式和真啤酒一模一样。而我显然不知道自己在做什么。好吧，帕姆和梅雷迪思的感情越来越深厚了。
No one wants all that foam. You have to tilt the glass, tilt the pitcher. I mean, I don't know. No, you don't know. We were drinking Phil's special non-alcoholic beer. It foams up just like real beer. And I clearly did not know what I was doing. Well, Pam and Meredith are really bonding.
我太喜欢和凯特一起拍这些场景了。我们俩在一起度过了整整一个晚上，只有我们俩。你知道，帕姆说她对梅雷迪思作为单亲母亲的生活产生了新的敬意。帕姆还赞美了梅雷迪思新剃的光头，说，你知道的，你真的很适合这个发型。你看上去真棒。你完全Hold住了。梅雷迪思说，哦，是的，我已经拿到酒保的电话号码了。是的。等下会有好戏上演。是的。
I just loved doing these scenes with Kate. We got to spend a whole evening together, just the two of us. You know, Pam says she has a newfound respect for Meredith's life as a single mother. Pam also compliments Meredith's new bald head, says, you know, you're really rocking it. You look good. You're pulling it off. And Meredith says, oh yeah, I already got the bartender's number. Yeah. Things are going to happen later. Yeah.
她要带他们去“滚床单小镇”了。没错。拍摄初稿中这个场景更长，我太喜欢了。梅雷迪思打算给帕姆一些关于独自抚养孩子的至理名言。我对此记忆犹新。我必须分享一下。请务必分享。拍摄初稿里是这么写的。梅雷迪思说，听着，你想怎么胡闹都行，但千万别把男人带进你孩子的家里。情急之下，用车库
She's going to take them to bone town. That's right. This scene was longer in the shooting draft and I loved it so much. Meredith is going to try to give Pam some words of wisdom about solo parenting. I remember this so well. I have to share it. Please do. This is how it read in the shooting draft. Meredith, here's a tip. Screw around all you want, but don't bring a guy into your child's home. In a pinch, use the garage
或者在门廊上解决。门廊。梅雷迪思说，我的意思是，首先要做一个好妈妈。帕姆说，嗯，当然，我永远不会瞎搞。然后梅雷迪思说，我从不评判。生活就是用来享受的。开个克里斯科润滑油派对。和神父滚床单吧。
or do them on the porch. The porch. Meredith says, what I'm saying is, be a good mom to your kids first. Pam says, well, of course, I would never screw around. And Meredith goes, I don't judge. Life is to be enjoyed. Have a Crisco party. Get it on with the priest.
帕姆说，我才不会干那事。梅雷迪思说，但孩子们永远是第一位的。那是神圣不可侵犯的。你知道我在说什么吗？帕姆说，我大概懂那个意思。梅雷迪思说，打扮成赛马骑师，跟宾州州立大学长曲棍球队乱搞。我才不在乎。但首先，孩子们。帕姆喝了一大口啤酒并打了个嗝。梅雷迪思说，这就对了。然后他们碰杯。孩子们永远第一。我记得那个桥段，因为我记得当时有一些备选台词，她会抛出一桩又一桩荒谬的风流韵事，但随后又会说，不过孩子们是第一位的。是的。
Pam goes, I would not do that. Meredith says, but the kids come first. That's sacred. You know what I'm talking about? Pam says, I get the gist of it. Meredith says, dress up like a jockey and do the Penn State lacrosse team. I don't care. But first, the kids. Pam takes a swig of beer and burps. Meredith says, there you go. And they clink glasses. The kids come first. I remember that runner because I remember there were some alts that she would just throw out like one ridiculous escapade after another, but then be like, but the kids come first. Yes.
好吧，这个场景以帕姆和梅雷迪思精彩的卡拉OK时刻结束。她们要唱《女孩只想寻开心》。我简直太喜欢了。哦天哪。我们收到了一封来自马耳他的玛莎·B.的粉丝信，信中说，卡拉OK唱《女孩只想寻开心》简直是纯真少女心的巅峰，也是结束这一集的绝佳方式。
Well, this scene ends with a fantastic karaoke moment with Pam and Meredith. They're going to sing Girls Just Want to Have Fun. I absolutely loved it. Oh my goodness. We got a fan letter from Martha B. in Malta, who said, the karaoke to Girls Just Want to Have Fun is peak girlhood and a really nice way to end this episode.
问题是，梅雷迪思提前开唱的那段，是剧本里写好的还是意外发生的？好吧，玛莎，我们问过凯特关于拍摄这个场景的情况，她实际上回答了你的问题。她是这么说的：
Question is, the part where Meredith starts early, was that scripted or did it actually happen? Well, Martha, we asked Kate about doing this scene and she actually answered your question. Here's what she had to say. That was like one of my most favorite scenes ever. I got to sing karaoke and I actually sing but I was told Meredith doesn't sing. So when I sang, whenever Meredith sang, she wasn't supposed to be good. So it was really fun just to get to sing and we sang Girls Just Wanna Have Fun and I just remember we
那是我最喜欢的场景之一。我有机会唱卡拉OK，我其实会唱歌，但我被告知梅雷迪思不会唱歌。所以当她唱歌时，每当梅雷迪思开口，她就不应该唱得好听。所以能去唱歌真的很有趣，我们唱了《女孩只想寻开心》，我只记得我们
had this improvised moment where I literally started too soon and Pam looks at Meredith and it's like, not yet. Like it was just, it was so perfectly timed, her cutting me off was so funny. It was totally improvised moment. They kept it in. Yeah, way to go, Jenna. That was perfect. I didn't realize that was improvised. Yeah.
有一个即兴发挥的时刻，我真的唱得太早了，帕姆看着梅雷迪思，好像在说，还没呢。就像那种感觉，时机掌握得太完美了，她打断我的动作太搞笑了。那是完全即兴的发挥。他们把它保留在正片里了。是的，干得好，詹娜。太完美了。我当时没意识到那是即兴的。是的。
Yeah, it was so fun. And I didn't want to stop singing. We were like, can we do one more? We think we should do one more. And they were like, we got it. We got it. We're like, no, no, no, we could do one more. It reminds me of that moment when Steve and Tim Meadows were improvising that baby back, baby back. Steve're like, no, no, no, we could do one more. It reminds me of that moment when Steve and Tim Meadows
是的，太有趣了。我当时还不想停下来唱歌。我们在想，我们能再唱一遍吗？我们觉得应该再唱一遍。然后他们说，我们录好了。我们录好了。我们就说，不，不，不，我们可以再唱一遍。这让我想起了史蒂夫和蒂姆·梅多斯即兴演唱那个“Baby Back, Baby Back”的时刻。史蒂夫说，不，不，不，我们可以再唱一遍。这让我想起了史蒂夫和蒂姆·梅多斯
were improvising that baby back baby back. Yeah, yeah. Steve's like, no, no, no. Yeah. It's the same idea. It was great. Totally. Well, everyone, that was Lice.
即兴唱那个“Baby back baby back”的时候。对，对。史蒂夫就说，不，不，不。对。是同一个意思。太棒了。完全是这样。好吧，各位，这就是《虱子》。
A huge thank you to Steve Burgess and to Kate Flannery. Yes, and to Jeff Hatch, the limo driver, for sharing with us their behind the scenes moments of this episode. Big thank you to you all for writing in your questions and your comments. You know we love them. Thank you, Cassie, Jordan, and Angela for my wonderful birthday celebration. And thank you to everybody out there for listening to all my tangents today.
非常感谢史蒂夫·尼尔吉斯和凯特·弗兰纳里。是的，还有加长车司机杰夫·哈奇，感谢他们与我们分享这集背后的幕后花絮。非常感谢大家写信提出问题和评论。你知道我们最爱这些了。谢谢卡西、乔丹和安吉拉为我举办的精彩生日庆祝活动。也谢谢外面的每一个人，谢谢你们聆听我今天所有的跑题闲聊。
I heard from Cody that there is a stack of birthday cards waiting for me at SiriusXM. They're gonna get them to me. Thank you so much. Oh my gosh. You guys really know how to celebrate a person. Y'all are the best. And I really feel like we have to go out on Girls Just Wanna Have Fun.
我从科迪那里听说，SiriusXM有一堆生日卡片在等着我。他们会把卡片转交给我的。非常感谢。哦天哪。你们真的很懂得如何庆祝生日。你们真的是最棒的。我觉得我们必须以一首《女孩只想寻开心》来结束今天的节目。
Yes. By Pam and Meredith. For sure. We'll see you next week, everyone. This one's for all you ladies out there. I can't. Not yet. Come on. In the morning and at night my mother says,
是的。由帕姆和梅雷迪思演唱。那是必须的。大家下周见。这首歌献给所有收听节目的女士们。我受不了了。还没到呢。拜托。在清晨和夜晚，我妈妈说，
when you gonna live your life? Mom. Oh mother dear, we're not the fortunate ones And girls, they wanna have fun Oh, girls just wanna have fun Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
你什么时候才开始真正生活？妈妈。哦亲爱的妈妈，我们并不是那些幸运的人，而女孩们，她们只想寻开心，哦，女孩们只想寻开心，感谢收听“办公室闺蜜”。“办公室闺蜜”由Earwulf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。“办公室闺蜜”由Earwulf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。
Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的高级制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。